[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible Bill Lawrence the creator of
Scrubs ever heard of it uh the creator
of Ted lasso ever heard of it uh Cougar
Town Spin City this dude has created so
many incredible and hilarious television
shows I'm thrilled to have met him and
I'm thrilled to have gotten him uh
through that boy Zach Graf to agree to
come on the show he's a delight he was
like chatting with a comic he's funny
he's fast he's interesting and he's a
wonderful dad that's really the biggest
takeaway I took I was like this guy's
like Dad goals for me really sweet sweet
dad so I'm really excited for you guys
to hear this episode uh only a couple
things to plug up top if you're in La uh
Bill talks about coming to my Largo show
we talk a little bit about him seeing me
there I do that once a month at the
theater called Largo in La go to
largo-la.com the next one is on August
5th actually this will be out after that
but there will be one in in September
there's one every month so just look for
Pete Holmes living at Largo go to
largo-la.com for tickets and if you go
to petehomes.com you'll see all my tour
dates in one place I'm going to be in
Denver St Louis Bloomington Indiana
they'll all be on petehomes.com thanks
to everybody who's come out so far and
I'm excited to see everybody who will be
coming out in the future they're great
shows super fun highlight of my month is
to tour around and do these shows with
you guys so I hope you can make it
petehomes.com and if you like this show
why not try a pizza pick if you're new
to the show we only do ads for things
that I actually use and love like modern
mammals look at my hair right now I
washed my hair today
it used to be in the past that if I
washed my hair I would hide my brittle
hay hair this this Disturbed fluffy
nonsense under a hat for two sometimes
three days or I'd have to fill it with
all these artificial products to kind of
make it look like I hadn't just washed
it it was terrible and I literally had
my hair uh my hair person and my dear
friend Kat was like Pete you need to
wash your hair it's getting disgusting
because like I don't know what to do
luckily I found modern mammals the only
non-shampoo shampoo I found that not
only doesn't fry out and make your hair
dry and look horrible but it actually
makes it look great it makes me want to
wash my hair it makes me wash my hair
when I want to have a good hair day I
didn't want to look like it looked when
I used regular shampoo modern mammals is
a non-shampoo it cleans your hair but
leaves it perfect like a perfect hair
day look look right now well if you're
listening you can't look it's less
structure still has some of its natural
oils and natural moisture and it stays
in place and looks and feels incredible
well after a wash it looks how I want it
to look after I would wait three four
days after normal shampoo but now I can
get it on demand and on command so now I
wash it all the time I used it before
red carpets I've used it before big
shows I used it before my Netflix
special which will be out in October so
this is the only shampoo I use if you
try it and like it one tenth as much as
I do you're gonna [__] your pans over 40
000 guys have switched to this instead
of traditional shampoo you gotta see the
reviews for this product they're insane
guys don't just get excited it blows
their mind and once you try it you're
hooked I'm in for life you can't go back
to regular horrible shampoo after this
and I love that it's a small punk rock
company I know the owner I love the
owner it's Grassroots these guys were
just fed up with shampoo frying their
hair and set out to actually create new
products to wash your hair with new
shampoo Alternatives specifically for
guys they have a bar for people who want
to be Earth conscious and and reduce
their plastic and there's no fragrance
or they also have and refills it's like
a magic gray mud I love the feeling and
I love the smell and it gives you that
perfect hair every single time six
seconds a day perfect hair and support
this show which means so much go to
Modern mammals.com weird and you can get
a special combo deal and try both
products that's the bar and the bottle
which both last a really long time by
the way get both for forty four dollars
that's modern mammals.com weird get both
the bar and the bottle
for one reduced price all right
everybody enjoy my chat with Bill
Lawrence I'm excited get into it we're
going how you doing Katie yeah I'm good
um why were you late today
what'd you do I had
check your thumb
turn your finger yeah dude if you get
surgery it [__] sucks it does surgery
yeah sucks I don't like to I don't like
the gun reference yeah
it's called trigger finger I don't know
dupa Trends contract sure sure see
that's transphobia it's dupa transphobia
that they didn't call it dupatron's
contracture did you get surgery no
because of xiaflex
[Music]
it's true Joe Namath or somebody is the
spokesperson for zyaflex and that it's
gross though they inject it so it's like
a it's like a calcification of a tendon
on your hand sure that's not even true
sure but uh as a man who's Googled
doctor terms and just put out all sorts
of fallacies
let me come to mind do you remember
something you've written that's just
like that wasn't right at all yeah yeah
there's a uh there's a whole premise for
an episode that actually has a thousand
years ago
um look the dude the real JD was my
college roommate and he's a cardiologist
and a heart surgeon out here he's a
great dude and our one rule was every
once while he'd be like if it's too
ridiculous you can't do it and uh oh
you'd call him yeah well he he he and
his wife were paying off med school
loans to the medical advisors on the
show
um and everybody called him real is his
nickname because he's the real JD uh but
the uh all right hey Rio and uh uh but
we a whole episode revolved around
um one out of every three people that
enters into a hospital you know is gonna
die and you know Zach gets a patient
Sarah chalk gets a patient and Don
Faison gets patient it's a really good
episode I won a bunch of awards and I
gave him the script he's the medical
advisor and he's like you know that's
not true at all
how could it be true though for the show
and it was he had to dig in and it was
if you stay overnight which we didn't
say
um and you're not talking about
um babies or
um Sports surgery than one out of every
three people does which are the ones
nobody when you go to a hospital it's
funny you don't think of all the life
that's coming out of a hospital yes as a
father you know there's this whole Ward
it is just happy yeah I mean I know
complications happen and there's there's
certain drama around the Maternity Ward
but I mean it's also just like a very
deeply joyful Place yeah only it's Al
creepy and horrifying place but yes oh I
agree with that yeah I'm not a huge fan
you don't have to say where your babies
were born where my babies were born our
daughter was born in Cedars ours were
out in the yard
squad on the full moon
until it was a full moon oh I said it
only because my wife listen to this and
she's so
no judgment except judgment she's so
against the uh babies in the bathtubs
and the oh she doesn't like that the
natural you know that little pool
skimmer takes out the poop yeah
she's big of you know you don't get a
trophy [__] do it with medicine yeah
and I came to a head recently I don't
know why because just after this many
years of being with somebody I just love
who she is as a person so much and she
actually said this out loud so she's
talking to somebody and who's like oh
yeah I'm planning we're gonna do uh a
baby at home in the tub with that and
before that lady finished the sentence
my wife went we can't be friends
[Laughter]
it's okay you can finish your story with
other people we can't be friends it
makes me mad are you married to Chelsea
Peretti who is this who fires that clean
uh my wife is an actress her name is
Krista Miller yes I know this I know but
she plays a slightly nicer version of
herself on TV yeah yeah I feel that I'm
actually drawing Chelsea being one of
those yeah she's been drawn to people
that just say I wish I had the courage
to be that Frank I do it but I'll give
you I've started trying but I'm not
great at it well you know there's
kindness yeah sometimes my friend like I
was having lunch with a couple friends
and and the wife I said I just love
being here and I meant the town we live
in and she said you mean here this
restaurant and I was like no no I mean I
do love being here but I just mean here
yeah and and I was like but that that
was a fair like I understand why he said
that and then her husband who's kind of
like a sass was like it's not fair
obviously you meant here and I was like
yeah but it's called kindness but
everybody was enjoying everyone it was
all part of the dance it was fine but
the example I wanted to give you I was
thinking about it because your daughter
is an incredible musician oh so nice no
her name is Chris Charlotte Charlotte
Lawrence you know that you had the right
letter
yeah okay sure um I didn't know that
world's worst psychic it's a CH though
no yeah it's a CH fine can I tell you
when I was a single man yeah one of the
ways that I would just meet people it
didn't have to be girls men and women
just out of bars kind of mingling yeah
was I would just go up and say I'm not a
psychic but I'm gonna try and I would
say like for you I would say your mom
and your dad's name is George don't and
I go don't correct me till the end yeah
and your mom's name is Helen sure and
your mom loves wine but stop drinking
but doesn't consider wine drinking sure
like I'd say something very specific and
then you you can tell me what your
parents are yeah I'd probably sleep with
you right
well you know the one thing the one
thing's so specific well it is
I feel like um easier in that game just
because uh because look at me right
right now if you
you if you without Chandler Well yeah if
you guys
you look almost like like in my mind
sometimes I recast you yeah as Matthew
Perry that's very hard for me but then
when I see oh tell me I wrote on the
first year of that show and I went from
being jokingly they said uh hey it's
like Maddie's fatter older brother to
his skinnier younger brother to his
fatter younger brother to his skinnier
older brother
we had similar sensibilities yes we were
uh uh we became friendly my wife was
friends with him growing up out here and
in fact I tricked her into admitting
that she slept with him at one point
which was really funny you must have
done the psychic though what's that no I
did I did a a better one he was on
Scrubs I want to tell him the story so
he was a train wreck already he was on
that's my uh one of my favorite Steve
Martin house yeah right uh oh you have
to I'll get back to this we have to stop
me I'm such a comedy fan I sense myself
doing it that I often will get into the
vocal rhythms of comedians that I like
yeah and I used to do that when I was
younger to my own detriment but if you
are doing the type of banter that I
enjoy so much I'll start doing it as
well and you're allowed to raise your
hand and say I'm doing you okay oh but
it's mirroring social mirror it very
badly with Comics though oh interesting
you know why I can't listen to say Bill
Burr yeah or Brian Regan certainly Brian
Regan was the first I worked with him
for a second and I used to do you know
oh no you know oh no I woke up and I did
nothing oh no you know what I say almost
every day it's from when it's from he's
driving himself to the emergency room
yeah yeah and cars keep cutting in front
of him and he goes merge everybody merge
you know what I thought you're gonna do
tell them you're shot
tell him you're shot people call me
dirty Brian Regan and I love it very
much you have a uh don't forget the
Matthew Perry I'm gonna write it down
people are screaming did you see me try
to Dodge I try to dodge
um
you don't have to tell any Story the uh
uh you have a third emerged everybody
murdered the big yellow ones yeah that's
me the [__] son that's how I would do
it you know you you have a thing that I
like and I don't I don't see other
people doing it uh so that's a thing
yeah I mean I really the uh I can't
remember what the original bit was but I
caught myself doing it in a writer's
room the other day of I was like uh uh
people get married someone just decided
that's a thing like so that's the thing
so I like how you look naked so we
should we should share money and maybe
have kids that's that people are just
like oh okay yeah okay okay
that really highlights but I'm at a
point now where I'm just like I know him
this little yeah but I've made my it's
not even amends I've just given him
thanks and been like I don't exist
without you and that's true by the way
of a lot of comics and a lot of comments
you wouldn't know their Regan is deep
yeah it's a deep down Reagan well don't
you find it refreshing when
I don't want to sound cynical but I've
often said like when I I teach sometimes
at TV writing and I'm like to to think
that there's a really a new idea it's so
arrogant you know at this point and it's
really just about execution and the
second that you acknowledge like for me
it was so liberating someone's like how
did you come up with scrubs and I was
like oh I smushed to The Wonder Years
and mashed together and once you you
know and those are the shows the shows
right yeah and once you get to the point
that your voice is this giant you know
mix of your idols and the people you
love it's a blender yes you put them in
a blender and it's but it's it's
immediately I find freeing when you
aren't in that place of like oh do I
sound too much like this you're actually
part of a collective I think the whole
thing watching comedy is a crowd's
excuse to become one mind yeah like it's
so great to face one thing together and
make the same sounds together like it's
this IT addresses this yearning we have
I would say spiritually to merge and
your slightly less spiritual but it's a
lineage it's like you're the product I'm
the product of The Simpsons and I'm the
product of Scrubs I'm not just saying
that the my first spec was scrubs I
never finished it but I maybe that makes
you feel bad I don't know
I was like I I couldn't I couldn't quite
crack it and I I pivoted to Modern
Family it was years later but the first
one that I was like I could maybe write
this with scrubs because I related to it
so who are the comics that uh uh that
made you love it certainly Regan yeah
but you know I was coming at it from
like a religious place too so I wanted
those clean boys so it was Seinfeld it
was Cosby yeah uh Scandal noted and uh
Scandal something happened with Cosby
Donald thing he did with Seinfeld you
see that with the yeah oh my God wait
what was it it was uh it was uh because
I went to college with Pat Oswalt yes
and Patton Oswald had told Norm he goes
you know what you know what I think was
the worst is the hypocrisy and Norm's
like I I didn't think it was the worst
and Jerry was like no he's like no I
thought it was the raping
I thought it was the right
only Norm the worst thing about Cosby
was the hypocrisy
I kind of thought it was the rape it was
just so hard to uh pull that off
you have to be normal so we are quoting
and we're even doing the voice yes so it
can't be lifted I'll claim it was AI
already so so for you oh uh
Cosby uh Steve Martin those are the only
albums back when it mattered uh that I
had downloaded Steve Martin's on my like
iPhone like they were on because you can
listen to them endlessly the googly
phonics stereo I consider the moon rock
needle I can do those things still I
would always have I knew somebody was
going to shape me if I could listen to
their [__] once and I can still remember
like I can still remember bits off of to
my brother Russell whom I slept with
verbatim yeah yeah that was important
they played the Noah's Ark bit Cosby's
Noah's Art back in church and I was just
like oh my God like comedy could
infiltrate it's the Lord I know what's a
cubit the most
unimpenetrable you know church and it
got in that's very interesting they also
quoted the lyrics that I Still Haven't
Found What I'm Looking For A visiting
Pastor quoted it and I was like Wow
music music's in church get in by the
way it's a penetrate it's a sidebar I
have to say or I'll forget I've seen so
much here stand up and I thought the
stuff that you brought in about religion
at the end of this last thing I saw I
thought it was so oh thanks well it was
so cool about it what if you're like
terrible please let me finish
um
[Laughter]
still things I think when somebody's as
good as you are at their craft you don't
expect them to turn the notch that way
and it was for me having seen you for a
long time it was a like a a little bit
of a dial turn yeah in a very cool way
it used to be I really appreciate that
that I would do that little moment and
then I'd have to say what is this a tedx
talk that was the way out like I had to
make it was it because of your were you
uncomfortable like did it make you
insecure it's a really good point I
would always think the crowd was maybe
uncomfortable but then my friend Matt
McCarthy was just great he's like I
think you're uncomfortable like you just
need to like Let It Be but then when I
married every point with some laugh yeah
then it then it became more tolerable to
do but it's really vulnerable dude it is
once you venture into the real [__] yeah
I get a real vulnerability hangover
after I do it I want to get it right for
those of you that haven't seen I mean
it'll be out in October but I'm just
kind of talking about the different
World Views God created the world
nothing created the world and just sort
of like
I don't want to minimize it and say I'm
giving it back because I'm not like I
can make fun of people that just use God
as a catch-all for the explanation for
everything yeah she's like God and then
they stop thinking about it I'm not a
fan of that either yeah but I do think
it's funny that the people that
criticize the people that that believe
in God the most most of them would say
nothing created the universe and I'm
just kind of making fun of that exactly
if I was reading I think it was created
by nothing
nothing happened
better it was just there and then before
it wasn't it's funny though now that
we're talking about it that is the most
afraid of embarrassment answer I've ever
heard in my life oh wow you know what I
mean you're just like it's it's nothing
and you like prove it it's like being a
kid and being pinned on something
absolutely where were you I mean nowhere
yeah it's also my girlfriend's in Hawaii
and my dad can beat up your dad it's the
same like yeah well you can't even see
what did my universe because you can see
that there is no old man in the sky you
can look in the sky and go there's
there's no old man in this guy but
nothing he just go like it's like it's
like wrestling with a naked oiled up man
you know what I mean and they just go
science [__] and you're like well I
mean sort of when I asked Neil deGrasse
Tyson about nothing he goes well the
nothing that we can find still obeys the
laws of gravity which means it's not
entirely empty yeah which means there's
waves in it I didn't know I forgot
gravity's away so he's like there's
waves of gravity through the nothing we
put a ball into nothing and it falls and
he goes so it's not really nothing and
I'm like this is is my point both are
sort of like words for things we don't
understand doing something we don't know
what so I love that you love it
appreciate it I I've been thinking about
it a lot because I just went and saw uh
Alex edelman's thing on uh yeah I saw
that yeah and it was interesting I'm
really you know I love stand-up because
last time we watched uh my boys
intentionally stayed home to watch
segura's new stand up was it good it's
really funny I want to watch it it's
really funny because the stuff he's
doing with his mom and about his dad's
death is really again it's like the
thing that hooks me is when you've seen
people that are skilled joke towers and
stuff suddenly are doing personal [__]
you're like whoa off-road yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's getting to the point where
that's the only thing that really I
wanted to do a whole hour on just that
stuff but I was like is that
insufferable I I can't tell because I'm
a fan so it to me it doesn't need to be
that I think people are looking to hook
into something I think I mean not to
segue back I think with what I do it's
the difference between
I used to my favorite things to be
writing a silly TV show you know that
would just make people Giggle and I
think nowadays if it's not about
something yeah people are like uh I can
watch this for a little and then I have
how many other things we have to watch
nine billion buddy yeah look not to
butter bread here but like Scrubs the
reason I was drawn to I know you've done
a lot of other things I thought you
needed me to say that I just I'm always
little hesitant to be like let's talk
about something from the 90s or whenever
that came out in the 2000s but um
it became the show that taught us that
like I understand Mash I'm thinking now
Mash did this a little bit but scrubs
reliably always in my recollection
brought it to something that that third
act usually over some beautiful music
moment and the one that really stood out
to me was I remember JD was talking
about how he would die yeah and he and
how everyone would die yeah he looks at
Donald and he's eating a big sub and
he's like heart disease and then he
looks in his reflection he goes stress
and I'm like a stressed out boy and I
kind of look like Zion I'm not saying I
look like Zach but I can easily you can
be in the family you could be in the
Hollywood lineage with Dax Shepard yes
exactly yeah maybe Ray Romano is your
uncle sure
he's just lurking in the background okay
me Zach and Dax are on a road trip to
find our father he's dying we get there
find out he's not really dying I mean
it's in black and white yeah we get it
um but I I really that was a show at a
time when I was like
craving a little bit more like what I
was watching wasn't giving it to me so
and then you know that impacted my
career in the careers of everyone in TV
I feel like we learned that right well I
think you know I think the overlap
knowing your comedy a little bit and uh
and crashing you know is uh uh I Vibe on
an undercurrent of my kindness and you
seem to you've already referenced it
here you seem to have
the same you used to joke I don't know
if you do it anymore about uh like your
youth pastor Vibe you know what I mean
but but what you're really saying is is
an undercurrent of uh I'm a good guy I'm
not gonna hurt you yeah I mean yeah uh
uh that was my Lululemon joke too I I
would wear Lululemon on stage and say
there's an unconscious message to this
which is relax
Ed
I think I literally say
he's okay no one's ever gone up to a cop
and been like he went that way he's
wearing Lululemon
I think most the shows I do are that
yeah hey you're not you're probably not
going to be triggered and yeah there's
going to be you already reference it'll
probably be a good Indie song that'll
tell you what you're supposed to feel at
the end and it's what I mean buddy we
need it
we're dum-dums
and you know people I'm sure you have
this all the time people's lives are
hard and if it I'm not
I'm not saying you do this you you were
making a joke that the music is like a
trick but like we need help no we need
help with our feelings we need and
anything that gets you through the night
if it's like this will cue you that this
is the moment [__] yeah I take no
offense I told three different things I
thought of it once so one was I always I
do have a little shame because I
remember when I tried to sell that show
and I only I've done like the first show
I created was this multi-camera sitcom
it didn't have a lot of deep moments and
uh yeah so we called spin shitty for fun
and the uh it's fun not because it's
shitty but because it's fun to say it's
been shitty
[Laughter]
I remember trying to sell scrubs and
this became the joke in the writer's
room because they're like I don't think
you can switch gears from broad goofy
comedy to moments like that people will
care emotionally and I I said I don't
know I think you can if you just turn
the lights down and play an indie song
and I was half joking yeah and then 9
000 episodes of the get something by the
national yes so funny yeah uh Doogie
Howser yeah kind of paved the way a
little bit because I remember watching
that being like oh he's at his computer
he's writing we're going to learn the
lesson but I feel this way about life
well you need help also
there's weird I I'm way into words
really that's a that's fascinating
people who can't speak well they just
lack a certain
Zach
but you use the word we use the word
manipulative like it's a bad thing
because with human beings in your
personal relationship yes it is but it's
just a word that's actually your
ultimate goal when you're a comic or a
writer is to be effectively manipulative
yeah exactly right what a bummer when
people don't feel the way that you
intended to manipulate them to feel oh
my God that's why I like card
manipulation like magic is called card
manipulation and I'm like that's what it
is and and comedy is word manipulation
yes you're trying to make people be sad
and me sad happy angry whatever that's
right I tell my I've been telling my
daughter this sounds so stupid but
forgive forgive and forget sure there's
this myth called the toe bone and the
tooth that this director named Carlson
uh just told me about and she said you
have to listen to it and I listen to it
and it's incredible it's like five hours
long it's like a Mayan creation method
it's an unbelievable it sounds so boring
even as I'm saying yeah
I'm listening to it and I'm I've started
telling it to my daughter at night yeah
talk about manipulation I have to stop
telling the story because her eyes
dilate to the size of dinner plates and
she she just stares at me the whole time
it's like one of those like boy falls in
love with a goddess in the woods and
they want to get married
yeah but there's a lot of danger and
like use my cloak and say my name and it
will protect you from the fire and all
this stuff so my daughter's not used to
stories with like and there's hunting
there's like killing nothing dies but
you know what I mean it's like that and
I'm like this is intense manipulation
like I've manipulated her so hard and
she's loving what a gift you've given
her to love that [__] you can almost
draw us you know my kids are older
um and you can almost draw a straight
line from you and your wife doing that
and having kids that love stories and
storytelling that's right and what a
gift yeah and you manipulated that and
you made it happen that's right yeah and
comedy is magically and also like these
are containers you're teaching so indie
songs is also teaching people when they
have those feelings they can also turn
to music they can turn to Art they can
trust part to carry them through yeah
people that are just out there like
freewheeling it without story yeah it's
[__] I know we maybe we're sounding
self-important but I think story is so
important I hope so boy I hope so
otherwise I've really miscalculated the
uh by the way because you have a uh
you're a national fan right I'm a huge
International so this is uh it's a I do
non Secours too often so you can always
stop me or driving me back and I guess
what I slept with Matthew Perry we
always that never happened the uh
I was laughing the other day because the
bands that you and I
would wait in line for and would lose
our minds overseeing most of these bands
now because my daughter is a
singer-songwriter and her friends were
singer songwriters and the people that
usually produce and co-write their
albums yes are these icons yes and to
them they're just old guys with kids
that's so weird with for me and I was
just thinking about because Charlotte is
her friend Gracie Abrams her whole new
album is produced by the guy from the
national Matt Bernier yeah and then
Charlotte's whole new album is produced
by this guy named Ben Gibbard who is uh
Death Cab for Cutie in postal service
and when you hear those two talk they
talk about like old guys that they
occasionally have to work with that have
barbecues and children I'm like no
they're icons yeah I heard the national
called Dad Rock and I was like oh it is
no you know it's funny I'm having I was
always trying to get the national on
crashing because they're all to me
starting in comedy feels a lot like the
national
I have a good show you come back and it
starts to feel like the national like I
mean that in a good no I know exactly
what you mean way and now I'm like it's
just me again and uh I was trying to
always get in there and Jed was like
nobody wants nobody wants to hear that
not just the national but like any sort
of he goes as soon as there's like a
mopey white guy singing he's like people
turn it off and I was like I love
it it was it was a moment I I wonder if
he still stands by that but he'd always
want to put in something a little more
upbeat I love it I uh I'm you know I was
a I was probably Death Cab more than the
the national but um oh interesting they
were both uh lyrically just is as if
they hey you uh uh kind of a doughy
white guy that's prone to deep feeling
sometime have a c that's right it was
awesome that's right yeah what are we
still doing out here holding our coats
we look like children these are
brilliant yeah it's also a very funny
line yeah like if I was like you know
when it takes like half an hour to leave
a party holding your coat you look like
a five-year-old yeah
it's funny I said that's old feed bridge
I was like a Phoebe Bridges I was like
if if I said I have emotional motion
sickness like that's a clever and her
mom's like a comedian it's like it's all
I didn't know where Mom was a community
we're also yeah we're all sort of like
I I don't I don't know to the extent
which she is Noble as a comedian I know
she does comedy okay no disrespect I'm
just saying I don't know if you can
throw her on Spotify no I just know my
daughter's brought these young people
Young Musicians like her into my life
yeah um and it's I'm so lucky you're so
lucky if you do a gig any type of gig
that young people it seems like a young
person the young people still wander in
are like wow a TV show or yeah
podcasts yeah and so I have a wave of
those young artists back in my life
again because of that let's talk about a
couple things I do want to talk about
execution which you mentioned sure I
also want to talk about the the yeah you
know what it is I do I drink this [__] I
usually have it with coffee in the
morning but I just had a coffee at all
time it's a wonderful I like it on its
own I like it and I like I don't like it
when there's sometimes if you don't
shake it well enough there's the little
chunk of green glue formula that's this
they just improved the formula so I've
ordered it recently so I might not have
the gunk the sediment that's that was
one because I I work with them I got a
email that was like here are the things
we fixed Godfrey Gunk free
there's no chunk at the bottom no chunk
no chunk at the bottom can you say that
and new no chunk at the bottom
I used to try and get the crashing
Riders to drink it I was like why aren't
you drinking it
cloves of bread I I didn't really feel
that way but you knew there was an
afternoon of like Thanksgiving tired
when I was on a show it was almost like
I know you know this it was almost like
intentional let's tell these people we
don't care by ordering huge jelly
sandwiches jelly sandwiches and then the
rest of the day you're just like a
dairy-based drinks that's it just gone
just go you ever look now now having run
shows and all this different stuff
knowing that they're all just people
yeah look at the show Runners the people
that
um Sherry and Ellen they were on Friends
yes did you work at Cherry Hill no I was
one year I got fired but we can do that
later oh yeah yeah let's go to that sure
uh they they were wonderful they were
always eating light yeah because they're
trying to think do you want to know
enjoy this
thing they're the only people at the
funeral morning and I'm just like
there's little pimentos
do you want to go have these and you can
get the sandwich I didn't get and I'll
get the sandwich you didn't get
um you know what I do they both have
Thousand Island I have a distinct uh
different way of approaching this issue
because I've been running shows since I
was a kid yeah and this is true and it
was with forethought I'm that person and
since they think that I could keep them
prisoner and I don't I want people to
have lives so I start every day off like
with new staff so I just go oh it
doesn't feel like a work day let's just
let's just shoot the [__] and blah and
then eventually the dynamic shifts and
they're like Bill we've got to really
get working
because I think people see the nightmare
of oh we're going to be here till
midnight if we don't get this dude to
focus
them there anybody that's worked on ask
anybody that you know that's worked on
one of my shows uh what's the thing that
bill probably says every every day I say
it doesn't feel like oh my God it does
not feel like a work day what are we
doing we'd be doing something that
mattered we can be out building houses
we help me understand it is it to trick
you into writing too no yeah I am at a
healthy healthy apathetic but I think if
you enter the Battle of I just didn't
want to be
the school teacher that's like we got to
put our heads down and work and have
everybody else be the opposite so to me
I was always like why can't I be the
person that doesn't want to work and
sometimes other people have to say they
want to work you know everyone who
listens to this show knows I'm going to
say this but this is like Don Draper
he's always leaving the meeting he's
always going to the movies that was a
little bit my style when I was doing I
wasn't Judah Miller the incredible was
running the room but that was also by
Design I didn't want to be the guy
running another guy [__] around all
right I uh um
I've notoriously since the beginning of
my career I coached all my kids sports
teams I still leave every Tuesday night
to play basketball it got really bad I
was directing an episode of the show and
I forgot that Tuesday nights I play
basketball and it's not about playing
basketball it's the community of it same
group of guys forever and ever go out
afterwards for beers and sandwiches and
release our workout and I literally on
set had to be like uh all right who
wants to call Action tonight from 8
until 10 because I'm splitting at 7 45
and I took off
[__] it man everything was and you know
what everything was fine
incredible yeah did you watch Blackberry
I didn't it's really good is it there's
a subtle message of this where they like
it's on my list of 9 000 things I have
to watch I've watched almost can you
give me some of these things because my
wife and I are like I got some good [__]
for you we just finished Dave which was
[__] incredible uh the beef when he
said execution by the way I was like
beef beef did a very by the way I'm so
happy for Ally Wong such a I I had no I
shouldn't have doubt it but I had no
idea she could act because she's
incredible and I'll even go one further
and say when it's Comics I go and kind
of go and like let's see if they can do
it yeah like there's a really yeah
because I know we're all in our head all
these things that make us terrible
actors she was [__] no she's great
Divine I loved everything she did I I
don't know his uh he started going by
his Korean I believe name but Sunny Lee
is a writer that I worked with and I'm
really proud of him oh cool he made it
it's now something like you can see why
he started going with sunny for the
white folk and uh because it's something
like sung young something like that that
wasn't me trying to be funny
you didn't laugh you didn't laugh I did
you left a white folk yeah I just didn't
want anyone delete the tapes okay so
sensitive um the uh and then Dave I'm so
obsessed with the actor that plays Gada
I think it's such a what is happening
that's amazing also once I was like
that's his real hype man I was like well
you're probably a garbage actor and then
everybody
never a false note yeah incredible and
I'm like please just I mean like I love
everybody on that show but it's it's
about Gator and Dave yeah oh and I
forgot what we're talking about and
Santino will give up a two camera and
Andrew Santino he's the king he's uh is
he on that show uh he'll tell you
that he's not on it enough
I like him that's hilarious he's a solid
he's a solid soft promoter man yes he is
I could be on it I can't do his voice I
can hear it but he's like I could be on
a little bit more yeah
um all right so execution we're also
talking about basketball you're telling
me about your Oh leaving and not wanting
to direct oh and I was telling you about
uh Blackberry yeah
and and then we're going to do shows
that I have to tell you about yes
there's the and the Arc of a business
and the Arc of the show and the Arc of a
person's life I was going to say a man's
life but it's specifically there's
something tight about men I mean in a
bad way we started out in the garage
like Steve and uh wozni jobs and Wozniak
kicking it around and it's pure and it's
and then it does just get and blackberry
does a really good job at showing what
happens when success gets into the
picture money gets into the picture and
they use it they the company apparently
Blackberry always had a movie night yeah
and this is you playing your basketball
you made the right choice in the
according to the movie Blackberry
I'm going I'm not burying myself in that
in the ego in the moment of all that
[__] because it's all gonna go away
anyway it's also faked it's of course
tell me go on uh well all right I was
talking about this because before I came
here is it all time meeting with a a
writer that worked on Scrubs and has had
tons of uh he knows you a little bit
Andy Schwartz he's friends with the the
score Brothers
but we were talking about
how there is so much I you know I
believe there's certainly a bar of
talent but there is so much luck in
capturing the Zeitgeist and things that
you can't control
if you ever believe your own hype and
that you really are that special I I
think buddy come on right can I do that
yeah
Ted lasso dropped in our lives when we
all needed Ted lasso yeah we could have
predicted that right it was so lucky it
was so [__] lucky it was look it's a
fantastic show you know what I mean I
know but like it also happened to come
when we were scrounging around for Tiger
King and looking for something and then
we didn't know we needed Fred Rogers you
know what he needed some hope but that's
what look in the scheme of things what I
mean is a big lesson I was very you're
very lucky if you have one of these
experiences Young when I got fired from
Friends it was such a I lasted the whole
first year and it was such a huge show
the very same people that wouldn't let
me meet for jobs the year before were
now like hey what do you want to do next
oh wow and I was like I don't think I've
changed that much as a writer in the
last 14 weeks
I felt the same way when I when we were
doing crashing and we're shutting down
places and filming on blocks where I
used to be nervous to walk down and you
guys shot at the seller too didn't it
and at the cellar too which was a place
that always used to make me very nervous
and then suddenly and this this was nice
it's hard I'm not complaining or calling
it phony but I am saying it's like not
exactly real you know what I mean is
that fair to say it's so like I
appreciate the kindness and I I but you
know what I was I was um managing it I
was going don't you dare believe that
you're a special boy uh because of this
treatment well I think that one of the
keys to success and Longevity yeah we
have to go to the minerals real fast
oh one of the key songs if you actually
have sincere humility about it and those
are the people that I see crushing it
still are the ones that are like how
[__] lucky am I that by the way even
if they're supremely talented yeah do I
mean but if you have a moment to go oh
I've been doing this so long I've had
this this last career Peak has been fun
because I never expected to have I was
having a blast yeah but I didn't expect
to have an another a lure on this song
yeah but yeah I mean so it's
I'm gonna have t-shirts made
can it say can it say TVs Mike Nichols
on the back
that's the most self-aggrandizing thing
I've ever said I want people to call me
that no the uh really no
did you read that Mike Nichols biography
I did holy [__] did you all right so um
sidebar again so did you uh were you
freaked out by my favorite thing so
unbelievably well written book Mark
Harris but
um his partner husband I don't know if
they're married uh uh is
um worked with Mike Nichols and they
were friends and so I couldn't help but
think even though I loved it that it
would occasionally get to sections of
like you'd read nine chapters about a
movie and then the next page would go
and then for the next two years Mike was
a crack addict and after that he did I'm
like
is that the same where where were you
you were just sticking the landing oh on
the advice humble I was gonna say
ability yeah uh so father Greg Boyle one
of my kindness hacks is listening to his
books just constantly yeah do you know
father Greg Boyle I know a little
because it was spoken of a lot and I was
involved heavily in this thing called
the humanitas foundation do you know
that at all no no
Gladiator I made it up to sound smart
humanitas
two Charities
it was started by uh God I gotta
remember his name now I'm gonna look
like an idiot I'll find out uh you look
on your computer Ximena tells father
father whatever but it was uh uh a TV
thing founded years ago that gives
grants out and gives awards every year
but tons of money for students and it's
always to Comedy drama movie documentary
new show that best puts out some I don't
want to say religious but kind of good
messages Triumph of the human Spirit
under father blanks kind of ethos okay
and so it's a it's a a great
Organization for storytelling very
important did old Teddy lasso get in
there uh yes I think so scrubs won a
bunch I'm more though a mentoring guy on
that thing and I'm on the we've been on
the board a bunch of years yeah what did
you well this is a dumb question let's
just lean into it Go Ted the character
himself like this is your pilot like you
you thought of this guy Ted was existed
Jason Sudeikis invented Ted lasso as a
commercial to sell the Premier League to
American Sports audiences and you can
watch that commercial on TV it was like
an SNL sketch it was very Broad
and screamy
um so funny
but it was Jason
um an American football coach that goes
over there and in the course of two
commercials gets fired doesn't know any
of the rules that is yelling and
screaming oh wow so you're like the
caveman and so basically yeah
TV can a good artist can come from
anywhere sure all right the uh the uh
and then but Jason to his credit I was
chasing him to do something else and he
goes man I did this character and uh
nobody will let me Pitch this as a show
because it was kind of Broad and silly
and loud but I'd love it to be
something with emotional depth and that
he's actually a kind guy and it's about
mentorship and uh because I had done
that in the past we were able to sell
that together nobody bought it except
Apple because you would show these
videos of this dude screaming in a loud
and raucous and funny and everybody
thought that's what the show was going
to be oh interesting and it was not like
even when we turned in the show Apple
was very supportive but they when we
turn it in there what the [__] is this
and if I'm thinking about that show I
mean shouldn't it have ended with him
being like and then you tackle them
personally you know what I mean like it
should have been stupid like it should
have been stupid I'm really obsessed
with when the first time you see Ted in
the pilot is when he's doing the dance
yeah because I went into that show like
a lot of shows uh just you know
skeptical everybody was loving and I was
like we'll see about that I don't know
why I go in guarded probably to not be
embarrassed I don't know and then as
soon as he was dancing I was like
oh like that was the click moment where
something else was happening what an
injury what a great choice to have a
dance well you know what's cool man is
we um
I I I like interviewing you too when I
asked if you did crashing for other
Comics but it reminded me of that
question sure but so when we started on
tedalasa the coolest thing is in the
writer's room you know you never know if
anything's gonna work and so we were
like man it'd be nice to work on
something inherently optimistic and
hopeful and even if it shits the bed at
least that'll be a super good positive
experience yeah you know and so as
shooting the bed often is this feels
great
once you succumb
it's because it feels awful and then it
feels great it's the key to life is
surrender this is happening yeah the
moment when you fight it it's the worst
thing that's ever happened and when your
brain goes maybe it's not the worst
thing that's ever happened there oh my
God I think there's kind of a profound
death comparison here too where he's
like if you could just stop it freaking
and Just Surrender and go it's the end
of all the tension of the strap I had
that joke where Jesus raises Lazarus
from the dead and it's like what if
Lazarus had debt you know what I mean
like he had like a relationship
didn't know how to get out of it now I
gotta break up with her you know it's
like uh sorry I didn't ask I did a bleak
joke on Scrubs they tried to sense we
had a very Samoyed who passed away he
was very funny comedian and actor and he
played this uh Sad Sack attorney named
Ted and he always went he we had one
joke that you could never do now as
someone opened his briefcase
um and there was a uh um the person
opens briefcase all that's in here is a
smiley face button and a gun and he goes
well one's in case I have a bad day and
once in case I have a really bad day
was that guy accidentally gets pushed
off the top of a building and we shot
like the old Hitchcock falling thing and
as he's falling to his death in the
middle of it he goes he gets relieved
and happy he was finally
[Music]
and he lands into a big pile of garbage
and does not die and is disappointed
I think of Homer all the time there's a
late Simpsons joke where Homer's like
and then we raise the kids and I work
for 10 more years and he goes and then
the piece of the grave and I was like I
just it's a piece of Joy thinking of the
phrase the piece of the great peace the
graves it's a bad rap all right to bring
it all back I had a buddy uh comedy
writer who got stuck in traffic and
eventually had to succumb to
um uh [__] his pants and he said it
was so liberating when he did it because
he's by the way he just said turn the
radio up rolled the windows down and
just and by the way in the gesture for
us became this we never said it again
and that's it filling your jeans
sign language
yeah it was submitting the bad w we call
it
that's not what we call it what it is
now now it is I mean what's so bad
relief warmth
I mean my daughter you know babies poop
their pants all the time it's a Mitzvah
yeah
they're really okay with it oh that's
really funny drop the story where were
we at about a million things fired from
friends let's go to that what happened
you were there
fired from my first three jobs I got
fired from Friends The Nanny and Boy
Meets World like boom boom boom fired
not just we didn't bring you back
friends I didn't I got not brought back
and and I thought I'd done really well
on that show uh I did do really well on
that show I remember it because David
crane who's lovely and actually really
helped me
um he created the show and at the end of
the uh first season there's a wrap party
and he everybody's drinking and having
fun and he was like you know what you're
gonna be great no matter where you end
up you know really I'm like thanks
excuse me I literally called I think I
got fired
um oh yeah but he he hooked me up with
you're gonna be he like kind of let it
slip yeah yeah but I think he was just I
don't think he meant to use that
language everybody had been drinking and
whatever and he was yeah and but he
called Gary Goldberg
who is my mentor and who I created Spin
City with and he got me that job he
essentially said you know Bill didn't
mess with somebody else up or on the
show personality wise I think he'd be
great and so he really hooked me up
Chandler um yes Chandler Bill keeps
showing up on set and trying to do the
ones it's not good that way my first
writing job I was that way I was like
always fraternizing with the Cavs
so bad I wasn't I was just uh uh you
know what I think my uh I was too
comfortable in the first three writing
rooms I was in and I used to tell
everybody that the lesson I learned is
that your job
isn't to sometimes the people that uh
end up being really good at creating
shows in their own voice or not good uh
working for others and you're it's very
hard to learn the job that your job is
not to do what you think is funny yeah
is to do what those people think is
funny wow you know what I mean and it's
a really really weird lesson and the
worst version of it drove it home to me
was I still feel shitty about this that
I wrote on the first year of a show
called Boy Meets World
and uh I got fired off it but I thought
like I was a cool for school kid and I
thought the show was beneath me you know
I mean because it was for for young
people and whatever and it's so poignant
when I think about that now because that
show has such special meaning to so many
people and I you know what I mean and I
was back there it's like some [__]
dissing it while working on it yeah yeah
and it was good that I got fired one
pitch can his dad what's his name uh Ben
Savage Corey Corey yeah can Cory's dad
not also be incredible he's got Mr
Feeney and a good day he's got it all he
should have a [__] Dad no no no they're
all great they're all great
thanks for watching crave the Mr Feeney
you know but I was like but he could
also just go to his dad like his dad was
awesome his dad's also great yeah it's
great this is amazing everywhere he
turned everywhere is a good father
figure including your father they're all
good father figures look
my dad did a good job and I was just
constantly looking for those like on
Scrubs the mean doctor yeah there you go
I call him the mean doctor yeah I mean
Dr coxor Dr Cox yeah I mean who didn't
need that especially boys like me and JD
I know he's a character but I'm just
saying that like when you met your first
little the first like hey if you suck
you're gone that guy yeah I can't even
do it I needed that lesson hard as a as
a kid and uh
I got it and I think I'm able to
empathize and actually to Circle back to
what we talked about
I'm smart enough to be able to say it to
people now the way the things I wish had
been said to me right away well like
what your job is to write what I think
is funny not what you think is funny
yeah
um if you want to say things like uh I
don't love this show that's cool but go
work somewhere else yeah you know what I
mean yeah yeah keep it to your [__]
self that's also part of your job yeah
yeah it's another Don Draper that's what
the money is
yeah you realize Mad Men is about making
a TV show Once you figure that out
you're like ah I love when you find out
that shows are really about like uh
somebody once told me and he may or may
not have written on Frasier
um but that Frasier was about a
relationship between a gay couple and
they wrote them as brothers
OMG
wow Nile's crane which is fascinating
all I have to add to that is one time we
were sitting in this house I go Alexis
David Hyde Pierce gay and usually when
you ask it something like that it'll go
this is what I found on the internet
yeah David Hyde Pierce has been in a
relationship with him it just went yes
I thought you were gonna say it just
it's you know chuckled and then turned
itself off
not relevant it would have been also an
acceptable answer like why do you need
to know how does that add to the
character it did though yeah I like that
he was I don't know stretching yes
um okay why did you get fired from Boy
Meets World uh I think for making it
clear that I it was not my thing you
know yeah
um and then the nanny it was a more
confrontational thing but I was um
uh it's all bad behavior I learned I
learned the hard way what happened on
the Nan uh the nanny was a weird
bureaucratic kind of not political Vibe
which was uh they hired two their their
people buying to be the new show Runners
when the creators were leaving
and one of them hired me as the new
staff writer and the others uh hired
another young lady as a new staff writer
and we felt like we were pieces in their
competition
and this other young lady who's a great
young staff writer did not put that into
voice and I found myself I created a
great I did I have a history of doing
these things Pete that are very
satisfying when I was younger for about
five minutes and then you regret them
forever yep and uh I felt that the
people on the other team were [__]
on a writer's draft that I had written
um because it was me you know and
because they're all jockeying and I
tried to catch them in a moment that
they had not actually read it and I I
did and then I said no big deal but you
should probably read it before you [__]
on it and then there was a a little
silence and discomfort and then I was
politely told that maybe I shouldn't
weren't there anymore but you were right
it was still Dicky Little Dicky yeah
great show yeah
I don't understand I was waiting for
something way worse I guess I don't
think you're supposed to do that when
you're the eight-week staff writer and
you're 24. you know well it must have
been hard I mean you you were young in
the room you were Doogie Howser uh I was
very young I I created it's been shitty
when I was 25 and those were my 25 dude
it's very weird
that's truly incredible I mean a lot of
people feel like they what is the hum
between feeling like you could write for
TV and then actually doing it I mean
like you had to have were you doing that
private well I was no I was um uh I was
trying really hard to be a stand-up when
I was 21. uh I got signed by managers
that manage only stand-ups named George
Shapiro and Howard West yeah science
guy's been around forever now yeah and
uh uh I was very lucky to realize I
could not perform
there's not a good performer at all but
I could write this stuff and even
friends using my material I knew I could
write dialogue but the big thing for me
was I was good enough to uh get a job
right in TV and I was a just a TV freak
as a kid and you know obsessed obsessive
about it but uh one of the reasons I
write about this constantly is I got
very lucky that Gary David Goldberg who
passed uh passed away way too young
brain cancer I had a honest to God like
see it in a movie Mentor you know so
when I got fired off of friends
um and I got set up with him he saw
something in me and I literally uh um
just on a date no the uh uh
David crane the friends guy called and
said you're doing a news he was doing
um DreamWorks first sitcom it was called
Champs it was not good but I remember
the logo sure then the uh and then they
started making sweatshirts that's a
different company
that's the logo I was thinking of it was
and nailed it the uh
um the uh you're quick you're almost too
fast for me I can keep up though I think
you're doing great all right thanks the
uh uh and uh on that show Gary was
really cool you see he used to talk
about something called a meritocracy
which is if you thought you were good at
something he's like oh the [__] EP
supervisor they're all just titles and I
was really good at stories and outlining
them so even as a kid he was letting me
outline stories on that and when that
went away
um Mike Fox wanted to get back into TV
but he said he wanted to do it with Gary
Goldberg who had created Family Ties and
uh his old Mentor he's like I also want
to do with somebody young that writes
these new shows that have like 30 scenes
like friends and so uh Gary said you and
I are going to create this show together
the one thing he didn't tell me it was
so funny because he literally sent me a
show running Camp the first year he's
you know you bring me into editing room
and teach me how to edit it's like do a
cut of the next episode yourself and
then I'll go over it with you and then
taught me how to talk to actors but in
my head it was all out of benevolence
and the show shot in New York City
because Mike wouldn't leave New York
City and it didn't dawn on me I was
there you know we were like three months
into the first year and I'm like Gary
it's weird how come you haven't moved
here and he's like don't worry about it
so have you figured this out
he was both a great benevolent Mentor
but he his family was all in La his kids
were here so he never you know it was
literally one of those things about
three quarters the way through the first
year he's like you feel like you know
your way around the block I'm like yeah
of course as I said who wants to call
Action from 7 45 to 10. he's like peace
out yeah whoa and then he he had the
greatest gig because he would come in uh
he wouldn't come be there in Hiatus
weeks but he would come in if he was
back in L.A like on Wednesday for a run
through and then be there on the show
and then go out in New York City and
then head back to LA wow yeah so you
learned fast what did he tell you about
talking to actors oh by the way he
always has this uh it's the uh am I uh
uh um or a good actor or uh uh uh I mean
a good extra or bad extra that was
always his favorite thing of someone
going so he's like yeah now you're not
an extra but no his uh is the uh
um I just watched Zach's movie and I
didn't tell him he just did it like two
weeks ago the show and I wanted to be
like there's a couple background actors
in your movie that like forgot how to
walk
like they forgot how to walk and it I
just maybe it was Blackberry I doubt it
was black bear that movie is really
great but there was a scene I'm watching
the show it was Zach's movie they're
going into this restaurant and there's
an actor and they're always just in the
middle of the best conversation
too and I'm like
poor guy because it's a wonder you can't
cut your hand I can't watch any of my
old stuff because it's all I see
just that way too he goes you only watch
his background actor there's one that
they asked me if I wanted to go fix it
and there's people playing tennis behind
Richard kind and somebody else and uh
um they uh
didn't even because there was no box it
wasn't making too much noise and you
couldn't see the ball because of the way
the fence and the whatever was but they
got into this Rhythm that they weren't
taking turns doing Strokes so they're on
opposite sides of the thing both at the
same time and I'm like what are they
playing it makes me insane I'll send it
this is life it's the worst have you
seen the broom that isn't touching the
ground it's a classic oh my god dude
there's a guy and he's got a huge push
from him
because I told him not to French I used
to collect that [__] I got there's a I
got one there's a pizza delivery person
that uh right before they they come they
they in the pizza that they're holding
it like this at first
[Laughter]
that pizza's not edible anymore my
friend
that pizza is gathered at the bottom of
that like a pizza bean bag
he's holding it
like a book on his way to class
truly truly good it's really good you
have that yeah
okay we'll cut it in because
we have to see that oh my goodness truly
okay
what happened with your wife and Matthew
Perry and we're
and we're back we'll be right back and
we're back and we're back to the uh uh
um you got it out of her I hear so
The Annoying Thing even though with my
kids my wife my wife is prone to having
these uh they're beautiful but like
she's huge into photography so all the
black and white pictures of our family
everywhere but then there's collages of
all her childhood and all the people and
unfortunately and I can give you this
too there's a picture of her and Maddie
back when they were young
um and I probably knew him then playing
um paddle tennis and all the kids just
think it's her and me so it's already
annoying and so all the time we were
dating as people are all careful she was
you know she was like no no I know we're
just friends and then we uh um had not
talked about it for we had been married
for eight years eight years and Matt and
I was still friends with him and he was
going to be on Scrubs and direct an
episode and we hadn't talked about him
in years and except seen him
occasionally socially and we were
driving to work together which we did
because she was on that show and I go uh
just casually I go is it going to be
weird like with him directing you since
you guys slept together and stuff and
she goes no and I go
[Music]
she went no no
no no no no no no no
how did you do that
well yes
it was awesome Kane and kung fu yeah it
was awesome I never mentioned it for a
decade and then I said it casually as if
it had been something we discussed on
ice for 10 years [__] oh it's
probably gonna be weird uh I just want
to try it because it's back with him
wow it made really incredible it made me
so very happy
somebody told me they went to Matthew
Berry's house once and
he had a he had a TV screen the size of
a movie screen that's what they said it
was like the whole wall I think that's
an exaggeration piece I don't know if
you when you stand next to a movie
screen they're huge they're really big
some of them are as big as houses that's
fair
and they were like and they were all
these they were like topless women in
the in the hot tub and he didn't care
Call of Duty with a life-sized like Call
of Duty Action Figures it's like you
have to have a funeral I like the guy
that's bigger than me I feel like he's a
friend I feel like that guy's a friend
[Laughter]
he raises the stakes
size of you
that guy was a that was a real
compatrium do you want to read his
backstory I don't I don't want to read
his backstory I'll never do it but
that's that's a sketch idea I have as
you do John Wick but every time he
shoots somebody you cut to black and
white and you do the obituary you go
like Terry had a thing for tuna melts
but he liked it he didn't want it with
cheese he liked a hot tuna sandwich
that's funny by the way you could also
do randomly in that show in that movie
cut to a dude with a beautiful little
kid and a wife he's having coffee and he
said he's going to be at the game later
and he gets in car and he drives there
and again he walks in and he's just shot
that quickly and killed and then and
then they go on with John Wick that
would make me really happy
that would be like art film brilliant in
the middle of the fight it's just a guy
eating scrambled eggs
oh yeah big day I gotta head to work
yeah what time's the game I'll probably
miss the first inning but you bet fifth
right if you guys get out quick I'll see
your first at bat in the second inning
yes
you should be the guy that just gets the
from behind of course yeah oh my God
that's brilliant and then the movie
resumes yeah then the movie just keeps
going
you seem like me in that me and Camille
one of the hardest laughs of my life was
we were watching some
watching we were just talking about like
a movie like mac and me or like some
alien movie where there's a live action
alien
in the movie and then like I don't know
where there's just like a hardcore sex
scene with the alien like the alien
and then Camille goes and they're not
even trying to make it look like it's
the same land it's just like a guy
like what is this is this part is this I
didn't read about this this is not even
the same alien
just non-sequiturs abound
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at element lmnt my favorite part
of my morning routine is drinking a big
glass of water with element inside not
only does it make it taste incredible I
love their watermelon salt flavor the
best I love their chocolate salt flavor
at night which I drink hot as also my
second favorite maybe tide for first
what is it it's replacing the water that
you lose throughout the day through
ordinary movement through exercise for
me through sauna through just being
alive and sweating here in the summer
it's replacing matte but it's also
replacing your electrolytes you need to
replace electrolytes to prevent muscle
cramps headaches and energy dips and
getting that sodium that potassium and
that magnesium in your body in your
blood first thing helps jump start your
day helps with brain cognition helps
neural connectivity helps energy it gets
me ready to go I've given it to so many
friends that say they drank an orange
salt after they they went on a run and
it basically floods your body with
everything you just lost and replaces it
and then some and you feel fantastic
element has become a huge part of my
wellness program I've given it to so
many friends I love the taste of it it
makes drinking water a pleasure and
provides the optimum ratios of those
elements of sodium potassium and
magnesium which is so hard to get in
your diet for health performance energy
and mental function it tastes incredible
I also notice when I drink one at night
I don't get up to pee something about
the sodium in there gives the water
something to work with instead of waking
me up to tea which is incredible makes
me feel fantastic before a workout
carrying me through the workout or
sometimes I drink it after my workout to
replace what just came out which is
awesome element is a huge game changer
so many people that I follow and love
online were talking about it so I'm so
glad I gave it a try I think you gotta
get it in your routine as well and if
element doesn't exceed your expectations
anyway no questions asked refund Posse
you don't even have to send it back so
support your body support this show go
to drink
lmnt.com weird and you'll get a free
sample pack with any purchase which is
awesome because you can hone in and find
your favorite flavor they even have a
spicy one which I really enjoy Go to
drinklmnt.com weird support your body
support your mind and support the show
we're also brought To Us by our friends
at ritual obviously conversations like
this with Bill where we're talking about
comedy and show business and writing
those are easy but getting Health advice
from your friends it's not really the
move ritual has taken the guesswork out
of the vitamin game they're multivitamin
for men is based on science to help fill
common nutrient gaps in the diet and
level up your nutrient goals it's an
all-around win the number one critique I
hear about vitamins is that you just pee
it out of your system but ritual has a
delayed release means it's breaking down
in your lower intestine and actually
getting absorbed into your blood that's
not just hearsay I used to go to the
doctor and as a mostly vegan I would get
updates you're missing B12 you're
missing this this I had deficit I
started taking ritual and now I'm
knocking it out of the park it's
incredible it's scientifically developed
with high quality key ingredients in
clean bioavailable form
it's got a minty flavor which I love
making it taking it a pleasure it gives
you D3 omega-3 DHA to support normal
muscle function immune function is
obviously D3 it's made traceable because
your nutrients come from and where they
come from is just as important as what
they're for so you can read all about
that it's vegan friendly non-GMO
sugar-free gluten-free major allergen
free and as I said it's Time released so
I fast most mornings and I take a ritual
and it has zinc in it zinc can upset
your stomach ritual does not upset your
stomach because it doesn't break down
until it's through your stomach which is
incredible the minty Essence just takes
it over the top so essential for men is
a quality multivitamin from a company
you can actually trust and get this
ritual is offering weirdos 30 off 30 off
your first month Go to ritual.com weird
to start ritual or add essential for men
to your subscription today I also love
their pre-po post and Pro probiotic
all-in-one symbiotic class go to
ritual.com weird start your ritual today
support your body and support the show
all right everybody let's get back to
Bill Lawrence
let's Okay what I was gonna ask about
like coming breaking in at 25 sure
all right let's do this would you would
you do us the favor of some of the
advice you give people who are trying to
become writers just because I mean
you're teaching it and you're doing it
and I'm sure people are tuning into this
episode going like I have an idea I have
an idea yeah but I don't do that can we
do that public service announcement yes
you've been in there before yes you know
no one understands is if you go to
somebody and say I have this amazing
idea that in my office or my college or
my family or my people should be a
sitcom I want to tell you about the idea
and have you do it uh if you want to
write that more power to you and you
should otherwise I don't know why people
say it enough here's what you're saying
you're going to someone and hey you know
how you've worked
for your entire life to get to a point
that you can do the shows and ideas in
your head
I would like you to do the idea that's
in my head and when doing this you would
get less money yeah that's right and you
wouldn't do your idea you'd do mine does
that sound fun it would be satisfying to
me to me your life yeah yeah the sweat
of your life to to get the rock that's
on your back oh put my rock on your back
and carry it through are you an amazing
historical figure or political figure
someone that's done something important
no I just work I just work in a place
that I think should be a sitcom stop
doing that that's absolutely right also
isn't it funny that it's like
this lights me up but not enough to do
it yeah but I think you should do it
yeah which is also insane and by the way
and it's also it's also a uh it's the
first thing that I say to people because
I don't want to be a cynic because it's
very easy to be cynical especially in
these times about how hard it is and it
is really hard but I can say the nice
thing I say if someone's like oh can you
say something hopeful I say if you come
out here as a young person and you call
yourself a writer and you write a script
from beginning to end that's finished
and has no misspellings and looks like a
TV script and is a good example of what
you can do even before you've shown it
to anybody you're ahead of 75 percent of
the people that call them self-riders
out here isn't that wild and it's
[__] bananas man the amount when I
first got out here I got out here I'm
old I got out here at a time that you
were literally calling up you know guys
and gals you know in college that were
funny at a bar and going get out here
they're giving money away you know and
anybody that was funny and quippy but
get yourself out here wow but the amount
of people that you would go what do you
do I'd be like I'm a writer and they'd
be like Oh I'm a writer too I'm like oh
oh what are you working on what have you
written nothing yet
but man I got so many good things up
here in the noodle
people think because everyone thinks
yeah and everyone has a life and
everyone watches stuff I really think
there's like a it's not even it's it's
too far to call it a delusion it's
almost like a an innocent mistake oh
yeah but that's the ultimate I could do
that it's the ultimate I could do that
gig I don't think people think I could
do that about comment a stand-up right I
don't think they think I could do that
about acting I think if they're like oh
my God I love that show and I speak like
those people they don't realize they
speak like them because they've been
watching it right and that's what
satisfied that's so funny that is so
funny I speak exactly like the people on
the show that I watch over and over I
could totally do this when I went back
after I got into comedy like full time I
was always trying to do but I went to
New York and I was surrounded by more
professionals I went home to my first
wedding and I realized all the friends
that I thought were funny friends I was
like this guy's just talking like Jim
Gaff again yeah like like you used to be
able to do that like you could just find
a comic and kind of talk like and you
can go to high school and do Steven
Wright ones and people be like that's so
funny when did you think of that maybe
like you say that because there was a
guy who it doesn't matter who he is but
he saw me at a show 20 years ago his
name is Dana Gould
a Facebook Obsession of mine and he
would no that it wasn't data but it was
this guy and he wanted to be a comedian
and I became like sort of like this like
my wife knows his name yeah I haven't
checked in on him in a long time but I
just was curious this guy wants to be a
comic what's he gonna do yeah and then
one time I went to his page and he had
this really funny joke it just it was
his status and it was I wrote that's
hilarious and then he wrote that Steven
Wright thanks and I was like buddy so my
favorite thing is my favorite part of
that is not just the buddy but is that
thanks thanks I I you know what when I
translated
he still took it thanks is the amazing
thanks yeah thank you thank you thank
you thank you I was either gonna pick a
line from him or from Bill Burr and I'm
like you know what's going to be better
is uh is yeah it's him that I'm a
curator I'm a comedy curator can I tell
you of all the stand-up comedians of all
the stand-up comics of all the jokes the
one that is in my life the most is a
Mitch Hedberg line where he goes you
ever Mumble some [__] but people don't
hear you so you have to repeat it and
then they don't hear you and you have to
repeat it now you're yelling some
asinine nonsense they're like what and
you go that tree is far away
so when my wife and I are saying
something I say something what is
inconsequential and she doesn't hear me
I'll just go that tree as far away and
she's just so funny she just knows it's
really filled a gap in our life she does
it to me that tree is far away I'm like
something like that with my wife it's a
way of saying like I was just reaching
out I was just pinging you like I'm just
saying something I'm just checking I was
it's a silence a cool silence
or is this like a really unquote I never
know or is it cool oh my God you did the
thing I like with words it's the same
word
do you have a favorite joke that you
remember do you have a like uh of all
jokes I have a favorite you may be
thinking for some reason I have a
favorite it was on a show called uh
police squad which was the the TV show
before they made those Naked Gun movies
yeah and I don't know why it still makes
me go I don't know why I popped in my
head I'm gonna hit you with I got mine
ready so Wesley Wesley Nielsen walks
into uh the there's a someone who's
murdered and he he walks into the
person's house past the yellow police
tape and there's a guy in there and he
goes he pulls out his gun and goes who
are you and how'd you get in here and
the guy goes I'm a locksmith and I'm a
locksmith
oh no
I don't know why I don't it's not even
the joke that I love is I I whatever
part of it well not only that I think of
the guy in The Writer's room who went I
got an idea he must have been so joyful
when he's like he's like who are you and
how'd you get who are you how did you
get in here I'm a locksmith I'm a
locksmith it's [__] perfect it really
it actually gives me the sensation of
fullness like it fills me up like I
don't need lunch we used to do the bit
in our writer's room of that guy saying
that and then he would gather his things
to go home even though it was only like
10 30. so I'm a locksmith and I'm a
locksmith so Monday are we going to
start at the same yeah one of my
favorite writers Laura guten would be
trying one of the best feelings in a
writer's room you're trying to get the
blow into the episode the whole episode
yeah just the last joke and if we get it
we get to go home and should do it and
she just yeah that's it we go home same
exact thing I I have nothing new to add
here's my okay two one from Naked Gun
because we have to now that we're
thinking of those types of jokes there's
a tall guy out of frame he brings a
banana up out of frame he brings it back
down half the banana is gone and he goes
you got something right here I mean and
then half the banana Falls
what did he do what did he do how did he
even get it on his face
he just he just wiped it on his
you know some the whole thing and by the
way that guy's who's always cut off
right below the chin perfect brilliant
sure I also okay so the joke this is
from a multi which I I my uh lockdown
shows obviously we're Ted lasso and then
uh Frazier we did watch all the Frasier
it's such a well-written show man it was
amazing incredible did you know I tell
you the fact isn't there is there a
lonelier feeling than if I went did you
know somebody who wrote on Frazier told
me that's about a gay couple and you're
like that was me I would love that I
would say nothing and I would go with it
I started to bleed out of my eye and you
know one out of three people going to a
hospital
it's a harrowing fact I don't know how
he does his podcast but it circles
around to him saying your stuff
eventually and then I think he just cuts
it so that he came up with all of it
nothing would delay my ego more it was
if I could have your wisdom you're not
here to write what you think is funnier
here to what I think it's funny just
something I learned from my mentor and
then I nodded and I take that to my next
show by the way thanks this uh uh
happened to me and I will tell you after
okay
they're at a restaurant it doesn't
matter they're at a restaurant it's like
the third Act is a big Crescendo and
they're I'm gonna get some of the facts
wrong but let's say it's Roz and she's
dating one of the waiters like but he's
like a busboy at the restaurant and he
the cat's out of the bag shit's going
down things are bad and the guy who's
the waiter he's holding a thing of water
he won't come over to the table
they're trying to get him to come to the
table but he won't because he's afraid
so then Niles finishes his water and
holds up the cup and he has to come over
and fill up the water it's the best like
physical like what could we do in the
world yes that's what I would always say
it's a pet peeve of mine I have to go
watch that writers I I know I didn't do
it justice but it's no but it's really
it's Chuckles the Clown it's what does a
yellow light mean it's one of those
moments it's it's in the world moment
exactly I always would say because it's
my personal taste what's happening in
the room where are we is there a fire
extinguisher is there a he's on the
radio there's a cough button there's a
joke there there's like something in the
world people just write these like hey
Jim my name's James
I'm just like they're in an antique
store can he yeah something isn't it
weird
people does I mean can you tell
inherently just the dev even in a
multi-camera show that people somebody's
writing it that actually hears people
speak as opposed to ones that are feel
like they're robots well I want to know
your biggest criticism and I also want
to know what you have in the chamber but
my biggest criticism watching a show is
this is one person's voice yeah yeah and
everyone certain people can do it Sorkin
can do it by the way you just use my uh
I always had pet peeves with Aaron
sorkinson because of that well yeah it
was because at Bing Bong your pizza's
here is it a pizza with the thing it's
got the thing on top of it the thing on
top of it spicy you like spicy I like
spicy I don't know if you can handle
this bite he's the pizza guy he doesn't
talk like that
yeah the the pizza guys
okay this one bothers me yeah yeah
everybody talks like that yeah it makes
me crazy I Aaron made fun of one of my
shows Once so we we uh Aaron
um I know how you listen to this podcast
the uh he uh uh uh Sports night was on
right after spin shitty and uh uh that
show was struggling uh and by the way he
wanted to call it Aaron sarkin Sports
night but the uh
so the uh um
um
good guy so uh uh I probably took way
too much offense but you know we used to
have to do the tag of Spin City they
would occasionally ask us to do one that
went right into sports night to try and
keep our audience watching their show I
see it's like Mike would turn on the TV
and he would do his last joke and then
that guy talking would go under their St
you know I mean to keep people from
changing the channel yeah yeah back when
back when we get cared about stuff like
that yeah yeah
and when his show got canceled he gave
an interview in the New York Times
magazine and he said we were never going
to succeed we were on after a [__]
show and had a talking dog and Spin City
at one point and I thought it was funny
had a talking dog that was voiced by
David Letterman and uh and it and it was
funny because it came from I went over
to a writer's Mom's apartment in New
York City and she had this dog and she's
like you're gonna love him he's 17. and
the dog had half of the fur on its head
was gone and it had one exploited eye
and every time the dog looked at me in
my head because I was always stoned too
it's just like just kill me please
please just push the TV over on me I
won't even move I won't even move to get
out of the way just do it and if you do
it on this side I won't see you coming
and I you know we did that joke and Dave
Letterman was the voice of that oh kill
me for the love of God and it was funny
yes and he [__] on the show because and
and then I ran into him in a bar and I
did an imitation of Aaron Sorkin to
Aaron Sorkin at a bar while angrily just
the way I just did oh my God is that the
thing with the drink it's the thing with
the drink is there a napkin under it
this type of napkin you like that type
of napkin I like the ones that are dry I
liked what I just kept going over and
over my show sucks you know it was it's
a different time Pete
I don't know what that means it's just
an escape a hatch from any conversation
what happened then it was a different
time
[Laughter]
because if a fight is a different time
man
that sounds like you duel afterwards
that's such a difference yeah not in the
bar we did out in the street like
gentlemen a gentlemen did you accepted
the challenge he's very you know what's
interesting about his stuff is when it's
something that warrants that importance
it's very very good like social network
yeah or or uh uh you can't handle the
truth want me on that wall need me on
that wall all that stuff you're like oh
it works but then yeah when they're
writing Saturday Night Live it doesn't
seem as important well yeah that I would
say that uh publicly and without shame
that that is why one of the big reasons
that didn't work
[Music]
you have tons of things that didn't work
don't you do you own them what do you
mean I I make mistakes I've had tons of
shows
tons of jokes you want to hear the worst
thing I opened with yes please oh that's
gonna make me really happy but I go hi
my name is Pete some of you might
recognize me some of you might be
cognizing me for the first time
it's ungettable
recognizing I don't even understand the
word until you said
cognizing some of you might be caught
there's a certain my mom has this my mom
you could come and sit at our dinner
table and say she would just look at you
and be like and that's why the cat had
one ear like she doesn't care if you
understand what she's talking about I
have a little bit of that where I'm like
they'll get it yeah and then be careful
my wife Val the number one note she
gives me is go slower and remember they
don't know what you're talking about
yeah they have no idea what's going on
they don't know what and when I watch
other comedians that I like yeah
oftentimes it's it's guys like me and
and they're they can be a little bit too
they fly fast and you say they skipped
like the whole didn't I say she had red
hair and it's like you didn't you didn't
you didn't it's a rick Glassman thing
it's exactly Rick lasting when he was uh
he's getting he's really starting to uh
find a tour yes he is maturing he is I
like that thing you did with him uh the
way we're circling back that was one of
the first times I was painfully Frank
with somebody
oh that was real the the yeah
basketball game the game he's very good
and all my friends who are not Hollywood
guys and you know this is their one
night out a week finally a group of them
came like what the that guy's got to go
it's exhausting and uh I sat him down
he's back in the game now okay because I
sat him down and uh I said uh you gotta
ask yourself the question you're one of
the better basketball players here and
you're always picked last and I said uh
uh by the way he started with the
evidence yes very logical you know it's
funny at the end he at the end of my
whole speech well actually I can hear
his voice he goes uh he goes uh one of
the best I'm the best
one of the best of the best one of the
best I'm the best one here I'm like
you're not that guy played for USC but
the that's not the point that's not what
we're my favorite Rick glasman the first
time I did his podcast first of all
since then now when I do people's
podcasts and I I told this to Rick he
knows that I've started going like I
have 90 minutes yeah you know what I
mean yeah we did three hours I'm like a
riffing dude I'm a cameraman in one of
your episodes he cuts to he got me to
put on a fake mustache and be behind the
camera and sometimes as a bridge cut
they cut to me in a flannel shirt not
even in my own episode
[Music]
you mean you shot it when you did your
episode he's like we'll just use there
and Rick's like could you also stay for
a half an hour and be a cameraman and do
some jokes I'm like what oh my God I did
it there's a certain boldness like if
Rick was a cell a biologist would go we
need these cells you know what I mean
it's like a fear the human race will
never die that's right yeah he's Ethan
Hunt but we were I was said I was like
you sound like Dane Cook and he does to
me yeah and then he was like no I don't
and or something and then he was like
let's call him and he called in I've
told this before and he's on speaker and
he's like you're on my show and Dane was
like get me off speaker
just like calmly was like you can't do
that you can't put me on speaker on your
podcast you can't call me
but he is Rick is
how I was and certainly how I felt
throughout junior high like there's
something uncut about that but aren't I
if you share the way that you and I look
at this work don't you look at people
like that I looked at you that way
and you get excited because of like like
watching Rick there's a magic yes it's a
faucet it's really fun I completely
agree people like that are inspiring to
me
um oh back to the circle so yeah I had
lost a I've been lucky I had lots of
pieces of [__] that uh
um they just were so bad they didn't get
on television or people don't know they
were mine because I uh oh yeah yeah they
weren't cognized yeah it was cognized
awful awful awful you know what my
biggest shame moment is because you
mentioned your mom is and I still do
this once in a while so Mike Fox on Spin
City we didn't use a laugh track and you
know he's so funny we didn't have to and
we cut things that didn't work but
because of that there's always
um a couple jokes every episode that
were just meh or absolute stinkers and
my mom went to 84 consecutive episodes
of that show she was in Connecticut and
uh and and uh whenever there's a really
bad joke all you can hear is my mom's
allowed fake cackle
I could put that on TV and it just is a
[__] it's like a fork and a knife
scrape together for me I'm like oh my
God have you seen that I think you
should leave sketch which one where he's
in the audience yes
he can
he's in the laugh audience and he
realizes it's a platform
to like complain about a business
or something it was like it's kind of
amazing that no one actually has tried
that to be like
that sounds brilliant man it truly is um
but yes the I don't know if you have Mom
shame with that [__] but you sounds like
your mom how's your mom view your comedy
is she what is she a monster fan well
you want to get a good idea of who I am
yes I was just gonna say she is but in
the wrong way
it's really funny man it's perfect yeah
it's like I was gonna say if you're
gonna write like a character description
he's his mom is a fan but he would say
in the wrong way because she loves me
unconditionally and my mom I tell her
this all the time I'm not withholding
with my love but I'm like she's the
she's the pilot light yeah like she lit
my whole like I believe in me and I'm
worthy of love and I can do anything I
can do it I can stand up in front of
people and talk even though absolutely
no one else in your family was an artist
before you right no and my mom even with
you know a weird Junior High years I may
I don't know if people think this is
weird but she was like you're gonna beat
him off with a bat like she just thought
she thought it was a catch you know what
I mean and that like that makes your
heart start to turn gold you know what I
mean you're special but like and
certainly there are times when I've been
feeling too special but like you know
that that can go to your head as well
but she she tamped that down with some
other Lithuanian style oh there you go
good for you but
the the example that comes to mind is
she she's gotten better and better and
that's an incredible thing to say about
a woman in her 80s as she gets better
and better that's when they really start
changing
that is so funny those are the years my
wife is always like your mom should go
into therapy I'm like well that's when
women really look to change is their
mid-80s that's funny I just work on some
things there was a 90 year old cello
player who practiced every day and they
asked him why do you practice and he
said because I think I'm improving and I
was like that's beautiful though I was
like that's we should all be so lucky to
have that beginner's mind but anyway I'm
sorry my mom will watch a special but
she'll bring her church friends over and
all she says is how humiliated she was
with the language or whatever and you
can see why I I especially real it's
like Richard Rohr and and father Boyle
and
people who love God and love me and can
look the other way when I'm like and
you're [__] all over an electric
fence and they don't confuse that for
something that I would say is actually
dirty yeah you know what I mean like
malice or yeah Envy or look like I find
a little fascinating don't you that
you would think she's gotten better she
wouldn't say that anymore good good
that's good that's just it I love when
people that you would think would have
such
disdain for Stuff appreciated on the
level that you just spoke about it's so
lovely and heartening yes I mean it's
one of the greatest Joys it was so
Richard Rohr who's just he's my
spiritual father he's a huge deal to me
I love him very dearly out of nowhere
wrote me an email he watched my special
and he's like I'm lucky to know you oh
how cool I was like
love is so easy yeah that sometimes when
you see it you go like it's not that
hard yeah it it's it's it's recognition
we're recognizing it is it's it's
basically just recognizing
it's recognizing the feelings that were
tossed back at you it's when you
cognized so I was listening to Father
Boyle's one of his books barking to the
choir and and he quotes somebody that
says um wage peace with your listening
yeah and I was like
well that should I I was literally I
should put it above the guest's head
wage peace with your listening it's like
locking on to somebody and and making
space for them and like not getting lost
and like oh maybe I swear more than my
mother would wish I understand it's hard
with yourself oh I get it you're gonna I
think the biggest like trial
by fire in in that realm is your when
your children get older and you go
through this giant period of time that
you see what you used to do which is
when they're not listening and they're
just waiting for the Gap that they get
to speak yeah you know what I mean which
I think is a product
especially if you're as fast as you are
I'm sure when you were young if you were
going to [__] on yourself there were
times where you're like oh I know what
I'm going to Riff on here in this group
conversation after that's right you know
just got to wait for a pause here I feel
a pause coming I have no idea what he or
she did five minutes ago and I was like
I can't wait to tell you my one from
Frazier you know like I had to tell you
I had mine yeah but yes that is what I
would say is look Jay Leno used to do it
a lot I don't know if he still does it
but on The Tonight Show there was a lot
of like I don't think he was he's
playing the trumpet
what about your moms so she comes all
these times super supportive but did she
it was it was a lot dude my uh the uh
the joke of it was I was trying so hard
to be a boss because the second year
Gary wasn't there that's 26 and I said
and my dad my poor dad you know he
worked
um
um they're still together but he worked
uh his whole life for one company called
Pitney Bowes East Coast Company sell
business equipment coffee machines and
postage meters and [__] and that meant
every Friday night after work you'd have
to drive into New York City from
Connecticut and uh and see he by the way
the show started Lakes Mike Mike had
Parkinson's and around 9 40 I would
always look in the audience and my dad
would just be spread eagle just oh my
God but I remember before the second
year I go hey Mom because I was back
when you do like 24 25 episodes a year
ago here's the deal
um I can by the way I'm trying to be a
boss and every time I walked on the
stage even before the rest of the
audience was there my mom would be in
the front row waving and I would go I
guess your dad my dad said oh my God why
are we here what's happening this week
um same guy yeah lots of jokes he's
short he's tall got it
um
before the second year I go mom I got a
proposal for you
um you can come to every show but if
you're gonna come to every show it's
just a lot it's just a big job for me
I'm nervous I can't talk to you and take
care of you guys every time and I said
or here's another option you pick 10
episodes and those 10 I will make the
nights all about us and week and she
goes everyone I'm coming to everyone
wow and I was I stayed on that show for
three years and we made
um in three years we made uh 26 26 26 so
I'm not good at math 60 78 78 episodes
in the first three years okay and so she
came to 70 years straight episodes of
that show wow is that bananas
I wouldn't I didn't want to go to 78
episodes that show Michael J fox
um what was it like working with old
smokey oh Daniel J fox he's just a uh it
spoiled me because what a great thing is
I'm sure you've had this experience I
want to know who the ultimate example of
this experience is for you when your
Idols turn out to be the way that you
would hope they would be yeah
um thank you he just mailed it's you
built to me I don't know if you guys can
see that that's so cool
oh
it's you don't say that though it'll
it'll cut that part out when he said it
to you
because I'm not about a glass minute
yeah
nudge it up a few frames if you put me
at the camera in a mustache he would
call you up and go that's my bit
um of course but uh uh Mike was so kind
and so lovely and I grew up watching
Family Ties in Back to the Future and to
be writing [__] that he said was such a
um gift as a younger guy he was
struggling because uh if you watch the
documentary that's out right now it's
still it's about as Parkinson's on uh
Apple sidebar yes you ready for a
sidebar my mom called me and was like I
watched that ridiculous Michael J fox
movie it's all about how he's falling
and he's he's hurting himself and he's
deteriorating
I'm just like
I'm like Mom I think he's trying to
share his experience and she's like why
why don't you get a walker if you're
always falling and you're just falling
apart and there's no she just wanted it
to be a movie like a Hollywood movie no
I'm okay yeah no I'm fine do you want to
attend in a dance number or your
tightrope walking or something like that
and she was just like he's just why
would you even waste her time and I was
like and I said Mom I you know my
there's like seven different moms and
I'm looking for the right one and I go
is it this one is it like do you want
philosophy Pete yeah and I go like I'm
hearing a lot of fear and she's like
nothing
I was like wrong yeah I I think in that
same conversation I said something which
I thought was so right on I was like mom
dying isn't the problem your fear is the
problem yeah and she was like she was
like will you stop it I was like okay
and I changed gears and I was just went
back to just like we're all going
through that [__] now man of right
watching these folks face that my dad
we'll go back to it I'll tell you it's
funny you asked Mike icon great lovely
best timing in the world so funny good
dude and then to now be 30 years later
in um Harrison Ford is on this show that
I created these things really
so lovely oh wonderful that's great
still a stoner and a great dude yes I've
heard that he's constantly still so
funny though yeah yeah it's my only
Harrison Ford story then we'll Circle
back to painful death mortality stuff to
wrap it up people what they want this is
how you know you think he's going to be
difficult so I get a call
from set remember you just turned uh 80
on our show and he he goes uh right
person won't shoot this scene it's in
the pilot so if you want to go watch in
the pilot he's shaving in one scene and
it'll explain it and he calls me I'm
like dude what's going on and he goes
the shaving scene I thought it was me
shaving at the end of the day like
before I went out to dinner I'm like
um nah man it's uh in the morning before
work and he goes well then I gotta shave
shirtless and I go is that why you're
not shooting the scene he's like if it's
morning Bill I gotta be shirtless I
shave shirtless and I'm like your
shirtless you'll shoot the Sheen and he
goes yeah I go what do you need he has
just 20 minutes to do some push-ups
[Laughter]
this is why everything was shut down
well this is why he didn't want to shoot
the scene right away yeah gotta take my
shirt off got to do some push-ups I
still have a little vanity this is uh
this is a new thing I just found out
about this yeah I love that too is that
you want to get a little pump going yeah
um
I don't know by the way you know what I
know I know that I've chosen a life that
I don't have to be shirtless ever again
but I want to be that's right you have
not chosen that life no I have no you
could there's a there's a better than 50
chance that someone else will only pay
you in the next five years of your life
if you agree to be shirtless at a
certain point that's right that's
horrifice I wouldn't I wouldn't sleep
ever again I read a script and it it was
it was that uh it doesn't matter it but
I
one of the scenes it mentions that my
character is shirtless and I was like
wait wait wait wait it's with TV's Mike
Nichols and I'm still
I brought it back I can't it was
wonderful but on the seizure I uh but
then I just saw a thing where Ben
Affleck was talking about how back in
the day they hadn't yet figured out
apparently now they have like weight
sets yeah so for people that don't know
I didn't know if you watch like Chris
Evans in Captain America and he's got a
shirtless scene he just worked out yeah
like it's a huge difference just worked
out and he probably had three or four
weeks of taking some medical help and
for sure everything for Marvel are you
[__] kidding me like [__] has to you
gotta get as big as humanly possible and
right before camera rolling you just
finished working out because all the all
the blood is just like just like Indiana
yeah it's like Indiana Jones sure
[__] me
um we forget how handsome Harrison Ford
is by the way he's still he's still he's
a [__] Silver Fox I get lost I know
I've looked right at him I don't even
know what he's saying it's pretty cool
we watched Valentine watch Raiders and
there's a moment where this is just
weird but I feel like you're you're up
for it there's a moon where he's so
handsome you go like what the [__] is
happening
like it's like it Bears mentioning where
you're but you don't I feel like he
doesn't get ranked like be pit T Cruz so
you're like Harrison Ford I'm Harrison
Ford
yeah yeah right and even now by the way
he can still get it he can get it yeah
yeah oh he can catch this
am I allowed to say that you can catch
it a consensual I'm up for it Harry my
mom is also obsessed with him and I
always wanted to introduce her to
Harrison so she can also I need to get
your mom a Harrison something
oh my God we need to make that happen is
that your mom's uh holiday gift or
birthday gift something from Harry you
gotta be or a message or a phone thing
or something right we have to do
something we just waited yeah can we do
it yeah
that would make me make you a hero a
golden boy yeah for all the ground noise
I've put up hi Irina
it's me Harrison Ford look at my dad see
my dad uh that's my dad framed over
there a little error you know what I
mean it's not oh yeah he's a little bit
of a silver fox same eye but he's got it
yeah and he's got the eyes and he's got
it uh yeah the kind of the gray that
started on the side she was trying to
get Harrison and she got Jay
is your dad still around as he passed
he's here he's still here I don't know
why I assumed that he was dead I don't
know it's weird you have dead dad
feeling uh
your dad died young didn't he no no why
no reason
oh my God that's the team is your newly
single and I told you about my second
game hard cut two you're at a bar and
you go hey I'm not saying but I'm gonna
try your dad your dad died young it was
hard no I said don't forget until I'm
done until the end I'm gonna I'm gonna
go see him this weekend
are you sure cause I'm getting strong
your real dad died
any any closer Batman is actually your
uncle these are the worst guesses I'm
sorry is it
that is you
ever that's your that's your ring answer
it she's a star
hey Charlotte uh I'm doing a podcast
with my friend Pete Holmes and I forgot
to turn and you're wonderful
content thanks Pete Holmes it's so good
I can't believe how good you are uh
we're I answered just for fun but in
case uh he wants to use it but I gotta
finish up here with him okay
the best time call me after I love you
I'll call you right after you're awesome
I'm not talking about you I promise you
want me to talk about you a little
I believe boys like you is available now
oh see you look at that
you're a good guy it was so good dude
you know what's uh it's like uh Billy
eilish Phoebe Bridgers yeah you know
what I'll give you oh that's nice this
will give you the giggles man is because
it just happened to me and uh
with my daughter I'm like you strike me
as a sensitive boy in a good way and
when my shirt and when my daughter uh
goes on the road I'll often travel if
it's so fun I've seen her in Germany and
in France and around different states of
America and then I only recently
realized because I'll occasionally wear
like a Charlotte Lawrence sweatshirt
like some of her merch and there's
certain songs that I get emotional yeah
because she's singing everything and
then oh he recently did I realize
because all of the audiences between
like 16 and 25 and they don't know I'm
her dad they just think I'm a 54 year
old that knows all the words and cries
when she says
get in the car get in the car I'm ready
I'm your daddy yikes
[Laughter]
it struck me at the last gig and I
really had one of those moments I was
like no it's cool I'm her dad and the
person didn't do this but for me
mentally they did the equivalent of like
okay yeah I'm sure you are no yeah
you're her dad and then there's just
like that kind of empty space around you
even though you're a massively crowded
room it was so weird it's so funny I
just just the way you were talking to
her just briefly I immediately had dad
goals of just like
I love how you post about her and I
loved how you just were speaking and
like she clearly like is a person to him
like she's not your merch no she's
awesome you know what I mean dude I'm so
my and I love my boys I mean not as much
but I do love them
way that other people can see how cool
it is
but they're uh they're they're so
gloriously dumb the way we all were as
young men oh of course and how old are
they they're uh 20 and 16. oh and just
Thomas rocks on Instagram a lot because
I scrolled briefly it would mostly be
different images of them stealing
alcohol from the house or or you know
trying to make their car drive while
they're not in it you know let me ask
you this so you you were in TV when they
made 22 yeah sorry it's okay do you need
something uh I'm looking if we have
tissues no I'm good so you have a lot of
money I'm not trying to be funny I'm
saying you have money how are you
finding that because you're raising
children it's really hard it can be a
curse right not not a curse that's too
strong it can be I was just talking to
my friend Rob Bell who's a brilliant
person is like isn't it funny When We
Were Young we just wanted to be rich and
now if someone's like super rich like
Dupont Rich yeah and they have kids
you're like oh no uh the greatest
compliment I gave my daughter is she
works so hard and your greatest fear as
a parent and and we can't help her you
know I mean we can't help her in terms
of she's never gonna starve she's never
gonna miss her rent you know what I mean
yeah but she's made and and grinds but
our biggest fear is parents and you have
to literally
be so you know uh uh I'm gonna say it
would be funny it'll be at my middle
son's expense the middle kid uh he's 20
years old he's home
and uh uh you know we give him money
when he's at College uh um but home
we're like yeah you don't get anything
man you gotta work and
um he got an internship that doesn't
start for another week so he's like
obviously I can't really get another job
until the internship starts so you guys
I'm like no dude you got to work until
the internship and this is how you have
to defeat these kids and he's like all
right he goes It goes so obviously it
gets better so he goes I'll drive uh
I'll drive Postmates if you'll help me
out with gas and I'm like cool and he
goes uh um so you'll do gas but I keep
the Postmates money and that's what I
can live off this summer I'm like yes
and then he immediately did this thing
he's so privileged and lazy that he
would I'd see him in the morning on the
phone he goes what are we doing tonight
um all right how much that restaurant
gonna call like if I had a normal meal
if I was hungry but not really hungry
like all right 27 and then we're gonna
go out for beers another 15 bucks that's
like uh 42 dollars okay and then he
would go out and he'll drive Postmates
for 24 minutes until you get that 42
bucks and then come home and sit back
down and he was living like that you
know what I mean and it just by the way
which is insane insane and so I
eventually had to go I had to go dude
how your other friends are normal work
week's like 35 hours at least yeah I'm
like you got to work 25 hours a week
until your internship starts and he's
like that's horse [__]
it's not horseshit I don't need that
much money I'm like you do need that
much money yeah yes you have to fight
the fight 24 hours a day well let me ask
you okay so with your daughter who you
love the most uh so she wants to be a
musician yes and I'm saying this as a
softy I'm obsessed with my daughter
she loves swimming I will jump in the
pool in a tuxedo sure if she says get in
the pool I'm just trying to give you an
example of like and that's her passion
like it's her first Passion is swimming
and I am in the pool constantly and I
couldn't be happier and it's it's our
joy time so let's say Leela my daughter
wants to be a musician there's this
impulse then with your access and and
your money
get her get her cars get her studio time
what did you do we walked out all right
I almost [__] it up I did the opposite
uh tell you a story that
it's not flattering for me but it's
flattering for my dad so I'll tell so
um my daughter was a is your dad Dead uh
am I obviously no he's alive
he's awesome
um by the way it's a weird culture
that I love the way it was said too and
now I want to just do it when I'm
talking to someone like at a coffee
place or something like oh my God the
latte is your dad
[Laughter]
no
anyways anyways if you get an extra shot
they're still sweet
um
did you just ask him my dad was that can
I tell you a bit Yeah sidebar yeah that
I'll never be able to do but I think is
the funniest premise of all time of
course we're all stressed out all the
time you look at a device
75 to 300 times a day that either gives
you an Instagram of my lunch or tells
you your dad died
that is the only comedians will laugh at
that that's fine it's too real that's
very real but it's we we have these orbs
I know like an oracle I know that you
look in yeah and it's either oh I want a
free iPod or it's like a tragedy or a
tsunami or something awful and why are
we on edge why do you think you're on it
you have the whole [__] thing right
here you it reminds me of uh because I'm
a huge I gotta do it I just realized I'm
passionate about it it's also a huge I'm
a huge Tom Petty fan and that Tom that
bit of that that's the punch line the uh
of uh where's where's he from you should
you should have to find that out that's
that's tell the story that you don't
you don't oh [__] the uh uh uh
um my daughter was a senior in high
school I was loving it I'm way into
sports she was a captain of a varsity
basketball team and a volleyball player
and she used to write music and put
songs out on uh since she was a little
kid no no one in her family has a
musical background but she did it and
then when she was a senior in high
school uh she got a song just because
you can do that nowadays that was a hit
in South America in in clubs and it's
called sleep talking and it was a big
song and lots of guys and shine she just
recorded it she recorded it she she
started when she was like 15 and she had
like recorded it and then someone
thought she was good a manager a guy
that used to do music supervision on my
TV shows said she's legit talented I'm
gonna manage her and so when that song
got out people descended on my house and
she was a senior in high school two
weeks into her senior year and they said
the way music is now uh she should leave
school immediately and go on the road
and she has an opportunity to have a
career doing this and I said on your
house you mean like manager's agents yes
yeah you know and and all shiny suits
yeah shiny music suits we're not here
for the Renaissance yes
they know about that term
but anyways so they uh uh I said no and
because she was in high school and our
family cares about education and she
didn't talk to me for like a week or two
and
um my dad called me and I thought my
dad's very conservative and I thought it
would be to say like good on you and he
said you're [__] up and if it was
your son and someone said he needs to go
to Spain and play basketball for a year
because he's so good he had already be
gone and you're being an absolute
chicken [__] because it's your daughter
and so I said you can go and she's like
I promise I'll give that to your dad you
can go you can go and I'm glad you're
dead
you can go you can go so wow and then
and then she said she'd get her GED and
she split she's never graduated from
high school she's been on the road and
women since then but she you know she
she has her own place she has everything
she made you know she's killing it it's
a different is that weird bill yeah it's
a different time yes
it is a different time because it's a
different time isn't that crazy it is
like again Rob Bell his son's a musician
it's a different time like there's
there's this opportunity for talent and
young people it just happens and she's
always gonna be fine because she writes
songs for she has a song she wrote on
the new Dixie Chicks album she writes
songs for other people she'll be fine
forever wow you know and I almost [__]
it up
can I say just to enjoy like Val I'll
tell real fast yeah there was this thing
in our town for rent and she was like
maybe I can rent it as a dance studio
and and teach dance because she already
teaches dance maybe I'll just take it to
the next level you know instead of being
a waiter I'll be a restaurant manager
and I was real like I don't know about
this because you know the strike yeah
kind of like dry right now oh you can be
convinced that everything's going away
forever that's what happens that's right
and I'm just over here I I'm I'm real I
can be very long-sided but also pretty
short-sighted meaning if I get a
notification on my phone which I did two
days ago that like I got a sag uh
residuals yeah it goes you have a
deposit coming your way and it's like
it's negligible when you look at my cost
of living it's negligible but I'll still
be like money's coming in here we go
let's go we're going out tonight
let's go to sizzling it's gonna be great
I'm that stupid yeah but if I go a
couple weeks and nothing's coming no
emails nothing it's over forever I'm
just sort of like I think we're [__]
and I get tight so one of the things
that I know the way obviously the strike
is impacting uh a lot of people my
wardrobe friends my hair people it's way
worse but what I've noticed is just no
opportunities like nothing coming up
yeah you just don't have that so you're
just kind of like a little freaked out
so this this to take over this thing
would have cost
tens of thousands of dollars yeah to
like lots of money but money you'll
never regret potentially right exactly
and I had that moment luckily it was to
myself it wasn't my dad but I was like
if it was me would I do it you know what
I mean but that those perspective shifts
that your dad very graciously gave you
yeah when you can call [__] and just
go like if it was a son I would I do if
it was myself would I do it yeah is like
a real we ended up not doing it but for
a more interesting reason because my
wife's writing a movie because I don't
really believe in it and we don't
believe in her no we believe it's funny
I wonder if you've come across this have
you read the war of art I mentioned it
all the time it's just a great book when
you wanna if you have a project and you
just can't get pen to paper okay it's
just a three and a half hour ass kicking
from Stephen pressfield he just tells
you why you're resisting and all this
stuff and we realize that Val has her
passion which is this film it's
beautiful amazing film and like it was
almost like this project which did come
into her life she didn't ask her was
like kind of a distraction like she's on
the path that she wants to be on so
that's why we ended up not doing that's
cool the way when life throws other
Opera I remember getting offered we'll
worry about my first gig as a comedy
writer I love sports getting to write
the pr releases for Madison Square
Garden oh wow you know it would have
been like hey you want to come back here
and see all your favorite sporting
events for free and write horrible
little three-line sentences to the local
outlets at Temptation I didn't do it
yeah that's what I mean the the Jesus
and the devil I'm sorry all these
religious things but like he tempted him
with power he tempts him with Fame yeah
you know what I mean like these these
aren't like
there's some what do you think so
do you uh you know who is a therapist
named Phil Stutz yeah what's that that's
cool he's actually my wife shrink and a
long friend of herself in front of hers
do you have any other cards uh what's
that uh she does she has them it's
really cool
we based uh Loosely based Harrison Ford
on him because I've known him for a long
time when he's shrinking so I hear
support has Parkinson's and yeah so uh
um
he believed you know I was never a very
spiritual person I just didn't grow up
that way but they believe in this thing
called the field you know and when you
talk about
you know Angels or demons coming into
your life yeah I mean and what he says
basically is he's like well it's
basically what whatever you need to work
on the most uh life's going to throw it
at you you know the field just brings it
your way again and again and challenges
and tests to see if you stay on the path
stay with your passion stay whatever and
he said now if you're spiritual you
believe that's another power of sending
it your way and he's like but if you're
not spiritual you can just believe that
you're acutely aware of it for the first
time in your life and noticing it the
same way that you said you suddenly
noticed pregnant people everywhere
that's right so either one of those
works but yeah I believe that's a I love
that yeah well spiritual a great way to
get people to uncover for their own
pleasure secret spiritual beliefs is to
talk to them about creativity yeah
because I can talk to somebody who's an
art and atheist and also be like have
you noticed that if you have an idea
there's almost a pressure on it because
you know it's in the unconscious yeah
and like if you don't do it someone else
will do it I believe that everybody is
spiritual whether they want to you're
there without a doubt when I say I'm not
a spiritual person I didn't grow up with
a structured organized religion but I'm
a massive believer in good begets good
you know in
um I want to believe so very
passionately that bad people don't end
up happy you know what I mean and uh and
that matters to me even if they're
winning I like to inherit to believe
when the doors are closed and no one's
around they still go oh I'm really not
happy you know and so that's maybe
that's Karma maybe it's spiritual Karma
I was going to say karma shmarma but Val
and I we talk about all the time how
heroin doesn't work isn't it interesting
that heroin doesn't work that like
something you inject it makes you feel
10 out of 10. yeah the best you can do
but then it comes in it takes a toll
yeah and then that toll increases and
we're in this weird
system and it's not just human beings
it's the whole thing is like pain
pleasure pain pleasure sacrifice payout
uh Athletics is a great example
childbirth is a great example there's
richness what do we fertilize soil with
[__] yeah we grow it in [__] the monks
would say we grow the lotus flower out
of mud my first show look it's silly but
this is my life it's my experience I'm
going to claim it it's okay came from my
divorce yeah I didn't want it yeah it
doesn't come from heroin it doesn't so
when you're saying we don't want Biff in
Back to the Future too to be happy and
guess what the reason movies work is
because they're honest about the way
energy moves in the world yeah that's
what makes my myths true yeah that's
what makes the Garden of Eden true it's
not true it's mythically true it's
honest about the way things work on a
certain level well any story or fable
that stands
time has to have an inherent undercut
current of um authenticity that's where
people just go back it's so Richard Rohr
we were mentioning him earlier because
literal truth is the lowest level of
Truth yeah I'm not saying journalism
isn't important of course it is I'm just
saying me saying Val will say how did it
go with Bill and I will say it was sorry
to be weird but I was like it was great
it was like we were friends we were like
finding it and I won't be like he sat
there
yeah then he spoke about this he talked
about Matt Perry like I won't say he
said the Matt Perry story I'll say it
was killer we were wiping tears it's
like poetry you know what I mean this is
how human beings died a couple times
but I would get I was always able to get
him back on track but he seemed I mean
he seemed like like he like it really
mattered to him
see I think that is so funny and you
know who else would find that funny is
my family it's crazy that we live in a
world where like that's one of the
things that happens well do you
um crazy yeah do you I'm thinking and by
the way listen to all those trials and
tribulations of humanity and now you'll
see those trials and tribulations of
humanity and now we get to this point in
our lives you're a younger man than I am
but that your parents are facing
mortality yes if you can't do this and
laugh your way through this [__] man oh
man you got a darker your toes that's to
me I would often I mean look there's
addiction and there's self-medication
all that stuff but I would in my head I
often say how can you not do that if you
aren't laughing your way through all
that pain I completely agree and I
actually think so I'm gonna quote it
every time I think about it Neil Brennan
told me it's a Neil Brennan original he
had an experience and what came from it
was to not smile is to tell a lie about
God and I was like that is gorgeous I
think that sounds written by someone
much smarter than Neil I completely
agree he said let's play a game did Neil
said or J.R.R Tolkien like it was like
it's incredible it's really good I
literally have it I'm going to write it
on my bathroom mirror because I want to
think about it every day but I say it
again so I remember to not I like the
negative of it to not smile is to tell a
lie about God oh it's incredible Neil
Brennan I've been thinking about this
[__] a lot my father
um he's doing okay but he's struggling
he has a type of dementia he's young but
he has a type of dementia called Lewy
bodies which is really [__] up is what
Robin Williams had uh when he passed
away and it's but we're able to laugh so
much because it's messed up I don't know
if you know anything about it's very
uncommon uh it comes with massive
hallucinations and this one thing's
called capgrass syndrome a guy named
Oliver Sacks wrote a book called The Man
Who mistook his uh wife for a hat and uh
amazing book about but imagine this so
once a week or so my dad will call me up
with um uh it'll be in a capgrass
hallucination and the cap grass the main
thing is that you think your principal
caretaker in this case my mom who he's
been married to since he was 21 has been
replaced by an exact imposter whoa and
so you'll get a CO and by the way the
weirdest thing is that doctors have to
educate you and
um
um they'll say you can't say it's one of
his hallucinations it's literally like
if I told you bill you only have three
fingers you're staring at your hand
you're like what the [__] are you saying
I have five fingers you can't do it yeah
so you have to say yes hand it you have
to say yes and you have to say you're
okay and but so once a week my dad will
be like dude you know he'll call up and
be like oh I golf pretty well today
things are going great am I cool
anything else and he's like there's this
lady here you know and by the way
sometimes it gets so Darkly funny
because he's like she's great and she's
getting me about the bill
I think she has designs on me and he's
like we've been married your mom and I
have been married for you know 55 years
there's not gonna be any hanky-panky and
I'm literally tempted to go dead I think
Mom would be cool if you [__] this
[Laughter]
the doctors gave us a trick because this
type of uh dementia doesn't attack your
audit territory stuff so the one way to
snap out of it sometimes is my mom keeps
a different sweater outside their house
and I'll literally go hey mom said she's
not gonna go out shopping or something
man she might be back call out and uh my
dad will be like hey Sue you around
she'll be like hey here I am she's like
good news she's back and it's boom and
it switches it switches off because it's
just sound yeah Mom and they don't
remember it is your mom dead no I just
said she's [__] it's not a tape of
her voice she's there wow that's [__]
weird but my father and I have our
relationships gotten deeper because it's
terrifying obviously for him but we joke
about this [__] and he'll make me laugh
sometimes in the morning we're just I
was just in uh Florida visiting them and
he'll come out with his coffee because
his hallucinations don't talk you know
and he'll come out with his coffee and
uh look at me for a second take a sip
and then after if he hears me grunt or
make a noise he goes you're here I go
yeah man he's like all right then we'll
start the we'll start the day he didn't
know yeah until this but he'll do it as
a joke do you know what I mean you're
here right oh wow [__] crazy it is
crazy and if we weren't laughing through
this [__] nightmare Fuel Man absolutely
nightmare fuel I'm reminded I forget who
had the story but he wrote a book about
his cancer and uh the doctor gave he was
like you have Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and
he goes of course I get the one that's
not named after the guy
[Laughter]
Drew said you're gonna be fine
he was like he was like based on that
attitude he didn't say you're gonna be
fine and you know what you mean he
survived it yeah he was like you have to
laugh at it but actually not to get too
weighty but what I was studying today uh
was a little bit about like laughing
what it's like Neil's quote taken to
another
extension it's like when you're
suffering you just kind of remember that
that's not the final story in fact I
would say that's the whole the whole
thing yeah no matter what's happening
you remember that there's a a source and
that sources
good and you will be okay does that help
you absolutely but I have to I have to
do it every day I should do it every day
you know what I've found to be the most
helpful as a therapist said it to me and
he said it was a joke and I don't know
why I just think about it every day but
we all when we're in those moments
whether it's your dad facing as
mortality or divorce or something awful
happening real trauma you get this
immediate feeling like I'm the only one
in the world going through this yeah and
I actually said to a therapist who's you
know I'm now close with I go have you
ever heard anything like this before and
he goes you mean today because because
today I've heard something like this a
hundred times but my career a million
billion trillion times and the second
you know that that it's Universal that's
right and that none of this [__] is
specific to you man it's just or even
that personal yes it's just sort of
what's happening it's just the journey
for everyone and then by the way for me
the second you uh 10 years ago if
something like this was going on with a
family member I never could have sat
here and said hey my dad is slowly
losing himself and it's a bummer and did
your dad die
she dropped her phone very dramatically
I'm sorry you dropped your portal yeah
you know I never could have very
casually started talking about my father
and that stuff but I think even just
hearing you talk about some of this
stuff it I don't know yeah comfort in it
yeah yeah I appreciate that man I my job
now is almost reminding my parents my
mom especially of what they taught me
which is to laugh at it yeah like when
she calls and you're like Michael J fox
made that terrible documentary it wasn't
the moment but there's another time that
I Mom that's not a scripted film it the
ending was so the ending was sad if I'm
going to sit through a movie like I want
a happy ending
bring it home Maggie find the DeLorean
it's not that movie mom there was even
another love interest he was just with
the girl who was with
but now is that your mom watches
documentaries and thinks that they're
romantic comedies that have been written
for her it was so rough it was so rough
you know you can sort of uh that's too
heady I can't even do it no no no I
can't I really can't I'm just looking at
my notes and I I
Jamie Lee was just in my house and I
wish I was I know she's wonderful I wish
I was in the mood I always when I'm with
her I do Ted lasso joke Impressions
where I'm like you you can see through
me like a crystal Pepsi
but then we do Ted saying things he
would never say but I can't remember
them I'm sitting with you I wish I could
remember them it would hurt my it would
hurt my heart because I can't do them
what do you mean I would it would be it
would you can't write them no I can
you have to say that yeah yeah you have
to find like a reference and be like
I'll Circle back and get you like
Indiana Jones grabs his hat and let me
tell you I'm going to put you right on
my head
let me just look at that
uh Stan you've done stand-up oh we
didn't I didn't we didn't we didn't
cinch the end there and it's your
Birthright to be on the show
you said you weren't raised with
anything formal or having some spiritual
feelings uh any framework
where are you on the stats
uh Force the what is it called but he
calls it it's called The Field they
wrote a book called the tools that I
think is really cool yeah
um you know it's uh uh I was baptized uh
when I was a kid
um not recently that's weird right after
the uh you can't imagine sir okay the uh
uh but only because my my dad's parents
said they'd throw him a party
um true story and and never went to
church since the closest spirituality I
had was I was a tennis counselor in an
all Jewish sports camp and I thought it
was great too because uh uh you know
it'd be very easy to grow up in the Mean
Streets of Connecticut like I did but I
got out
yeah
pulled myself up by my bootstraps took a
few corn muffins for strength yeah I got
out of Fairfield County Connecticut
um and made it on my own
that's horrible I could hate myself now
I hate myself immediately but uh I just
remember because there was this guy
um
um Bob Branham uh and he so badly wanted
me to be Jewish every year he would go
on the first day of camp he'd go Bill
Lawrence will lead us in prayer tonight
my name is William Van Duzer Lawrence IV
all right and you know I sound like a
Red Baron dude uh
why is that guy on a pizza box
and every year I'd be like hey Bob I'm
not Jewish and uh
um
um and then uh finally the last year as
a counselor there beforehand I went up
to his older guy and I go hey man I
don't give a [__] but it always you'd
always start the camp year for me with
me walking home from the first dinner
with all the kids going if you're not
Jewish well through your I'm like just
I'm not just it's not I'm not me it's
not me yeah and he goes I get you I get
you and then that night he goes uh Bill
Lawrence will lead us in prayer tonight
but more importantly I thought it was
my parents exposed me to everything and
so uh uh I'm not down with the most
judgmental facets of organized religion
that we all I could probably
yeah connect you know yeah but even
those experiences were some you know a
buddy of mine who's Michael Patrick
Carney whose brother killed himself and
watching that family unravel because it
happened on Christmas Day and uh the way
the Catholic Church especially when
you're strict Catholics like them looks
at suicide as no bueno you know I mean
so but I I do think I'm a very uh
spiritual person I really do believe and
I don't know if it's a tenet of of
spirituality or just as who you are as a
person that the amount of kindness and
love and uh support and mentorship that
you put out there comes back to you in
Spades I don't see people that do that
ending up feelings bad things can still
happen to them in their family their
lives but they don't end up feeling
unfulfilled or like they let a life of
uh meaninglessness I agree yeah yeah
beautiful yeah love and more love was it
Judy Garland I think it was yeah love
and more love no that's true and Fred
Rogers said love or the lack of it and I
to our point I don't think at the end
you're going to count the skulls that
you scalped you're gonna you're gonna
remember well obviously my last words
are going to be asking the physician
next to me if his dad's dead
wait this is like [__] your pants in
the car and I'm there and you just
and then you say we should give him a
minute you should say guys we should
back out or just turn away for a minute
he left but something entered the room
I watched this Soul leave but as he left
like a Neil Simon play another character
entered the room and he's taken up a lot
of space it's his turd this was awesome
man it was really fun for me thank you
so much for doing it I'm such a huge
admirer of yours thank you for doing it
back at you is a comedy nerd
um man it's fun to shoot this [__] with
somebody that does the thing that I
always used to have pipe dreams about
doing it you gotta do it
zebraf told me I did it uh I did I did a
TV show you can cut this out or whatever
but I did a show with all Comics that
they sent us on the road to all the
major Affiliates uh and I did the
opening 15 minutes and um did you love
it I loved it again well the first night
was horrifying State we opened at
Caroline's because then it was theaters
and and I hadn't done it a long time
weird that a theater is actually less
nerve-wracking well this is why because
you can't ever [__] see people in a
theater I've forgotten that yeah and
Caroline's how's this for a nightmare
fuel I hadn't written anything but I'm
good quick and I said I can do a lot of
my old [__] when I used to do this yeah
and I'd forgotten that my old stuff was
when I was 23 and trying to get laid and
that was kind of the undercurrent of
every job yes and I'm a creepy married
guy and what gets worse so I get up
there and I'm like in the middle I'm
like oh I need to switch to crowd work
fast and then I see in the lights to the
corner a table of nine of my friends
from high school had come in to surprise
me
um to Carol Heights
I hate this story well here's what the
only thing you're gonna like about it I
died in ugly death and then Ron funches
was on after me and he said I have to be
honest it did me a lot of good to see a
wealthy white guy be that uncomfortable
I gotta be honest
he said as bad as it was for you
it did a lot of good for me to see a
wealthy white man be that uncomfortable
and I'll tell you the end of that thing
that I I will forever cherish is that it
was me it was Brent Morin it was Ron it
was Rick Glassman it's crystalia it was
his you know as a tour and each comic
sometimes at the end Rank and one night
Ron actually said
um and surprisingly tonight Bill
Lawrence does not come in last
you know what I mean he comes in by the
way the nightmare for the other comics
of Ron or anybody ever rated me above
them on a given night of the theater
beating someone who does this for a
living is a man that does not do this
for a living oh no yeah that would be
rough but the difference is when there's
no pressure on you because you're not
trying to make that what you do it's
it's I could do it until the end of time
now I yeah I think you should if you
ever want to you could do my Largo just
jump up I'll I'll do it in a heartbeat I
promised uh Brett Goldstein who you
should have on here that I would open
for him on his tour at least in one
second my Brett Goldstein Joe tell me so
on the show of course it talks yeah and
everybody comes because the the guy
that's going to be like oh my God he he
makes me so humid in my loins he's like
I uh get away from me on the pitch then
he gets up and he's like hi everybody
so good to be here what's your favorite
film I like muppets
muppets so much little cup of tea and
everyone's like hmm I'd still [__] him
no that's what they're thinking no one
in the world is less like
who they're pretending to be like them
breakfast yeah yeah I've known him
forever he was friends of mine before
that show no way yeah I heard him on
that show as a writer and then he he
snuck off yeah just give me a chance I
think I can do it hey Bayou oh
be you
over here you know you know how I'm not
athletic in any way not any way I can't
even run the chest hair is like a rug
I've pulled up over my non-developed
muscles my muscles are just like yours
but I'll have a nice bush in the [__]
weirdest thing about Hollywood muscles
[Laughter]
I don't know why that guy's the one
that's most important there's no
cameraman ROM dogs
he's dead
does that do us anything it helps yeah
uh his dad's dead that's no one
is less like the person they're playing
in my entire life or career than Brett
Goldstein he's a sensitive yeah he's not
that guy yeah I know now I know which is
great it's lovely he's not the superhero
we need he's the one we deserve sure
isn't it hopeful though that that can
still happen right that nerd comedy yeah
comedian next to you can be yes and then
you can be on a train and someone's
going if I could be with any man it
would be with Brett Goldstein because of
how athletic and gruffius people forget
I'm Jewish people forget but it's right
there puppets I'll let puppets in my
favorite movie what is his favorite
movie I should know I love his podcast
that's good have you done it I did do it
what'd you say yours was There Will Be
Blood that's a great movie he said
that's correct oh did he he didn't give
you a good answer yeah that's correct
that's absolutely right all right that's
it oh I forgot to say the hardest time
you've ever laughed I'm sorry we gotta
do that can you think of a time in your
life where you laughed harder than
you've ever laughed in your life or just
weeping with laughter maybe you're a
little kid maybe someone fell maybe
someone farted uh uh so many of them I
think the joy for what I do is they're
constant I'll tell you the first one
that popped into my head
um
um I'm not done doing the voice
just now
I need to I need to keep doing it I'll
just love being Roy Kent
sex symbol you know I love it because
this is funny but you're also buying me
time because you can tell us you could
tell I was vamping it was good to play
football before that's by the way I
forget because your talk show is great
too that you have the skill yeah you but
you learn to do that you either help
people or you do because you said Jay
Leto you look at your card and if
there's a gap you think that the person
answered and you go so I heard you
bought a new car
no I was doing the I was doing the
hardest I laughed you asked the hardest
I laughed I was thinking uh what kind of
car I drive cars no I'm trying to do the
the hardest to laugh thing your heart is
Chaco
came home you can do it so uh
I was in the my family is a [__] show of
big personalities I say to everybody
that asks that the one common trait of
All My Children is completely unearned
confidence
all of them I know I got this all of
them 100
100. you can do it this person needs a
tracheotomy I got it the the it's just
absolute horseshit and they're all loud
and my wife always we always meet
parents with kids that are like yeah
where should I put this dish and you're
like what the [__] are you talking why
are you not just leaving it wherever you
are like my children and uh she's she's
like did we blow it and I say no
um the kids are so [__] boring all
right ours are awesome and exciting and
fun and we're in the car and we were
traveling in Europe because it was a
great idea to take the family and family
trip to Europe it's never a great idea
okay it's always horrible everybody
always screams
um and uh um is everybody's awful and
we're just fighting and I was jet lagged
in Sweden and the whole family and my it
was one of those horrible things that my
wife was yelling at my daughter my
daughter's like why are you always so
mean to me and she had been mean to my
middle son my middle son was like
because you're such a [__] all all the
time it was just awful and I'm like I'm
like yeah
I'm the dad in a movie uh of like go
just shut up we
going back and forth except my youngest
you know who's was 15 at the time and uh
and and then by the way when I did that
then my daughter starts going like can't
we just
making fun of me can we just have one
day that we're not enough of that [__]
we're just fighting you know what I mean
and then I lost my mind I stopped the
car I stopped the car everybody's
yelling over and talked to each other
and I go this is supposed to be a family
trip and uh let me tell you something
right now we're not gonna be mean to
each other there's no more mimicking
okay I mean it and enough of this [__]
or we'll just [__] go our separate
ways and stay in the hotel okay that's
it and then I put the car back in gear
and started driving and my 15 year old
after like five seconds of silence goes
no more mimicking I mean it
[Laughter]
they all started laughing at me and this
is not as heavy a joke as some of the
other ones I thought of but it was such
a family moment yes of what a [__]
tool caricatured old [__] I was it
makes me warm in my heart when I think
about it I love the that and I love the
story of your dad and they're sort of
similar when your dad called you I love
these calling out and I love that that's
where you go yeah that's what makes you
interested well because you and I could
do big laughs till the end of time I'll
give you a second one there's a better
joke just because I'll I'll uh you're
going to want to do this you know how
you used to do things the little things
you do for yourself yeah one of your my
favorite bits of yours yes uh uh it was
names that you say little things to make
yourself happy yeah yeah right um
Leonard Kravitz yes
uh I have a comedy writer friend Tim
Hobert uh stand up to great great uh uh
and um
whenever he's in a bad mood he does this
for by himself sometime even when he's
Alone
um if any woman
regardless of age as long as she's an
adult asks him anything
um he does a joke that he assumes that
they're hitting on him
and it made me laugh so hard the other
day we were at the grocery store
um buying Gatorade because we're going
to a basketball game that our sons were
playing in and the you know those little
bars that separate your groceries is the
older lady behind us is like oh I'm
sorry can you hand me that and he goes I
am so flattered but I'm married
um
and he goes he goes I can't tell you how
much you made my day ma'am you made my
day don't feel bad about it but uh
yes and by the way I didn't know it was
gonna happen she had a look on her face
like an alien had just dropped down and
it was the best I I [__] scream
laughed
do it for yourself to do it it's so
flattered it's so fun by the way you
have to have it yeah yeah you go you got
you by the way and he does he says
sometimes he makes a show of it and
he'll say I gotta tell you I was having
a tough day
and
I was having a time you've brightened my
day I was having a tough day honestly
um but I am I am married I mean I wish I
was not I wish I was not but I am but
you made my day okay we're gonna make
somebody very very happy
that is he says the more trivial it is
the better it is hey can you give me the
ketchup off your table I'm flattered
that is so nice of you I am uh I mean I
was sitting like this when I'm married
it's so fun unbelievable what a gift
you've given us yeah do that please
a gift Bill thank you nothing nothing
left no one cares your associate with
Sarah Lawrence it's my great great
grandma what's up
we slipped it in see if she's dead good
night
would you say keep it crispy because
she's dead that's how we're ending we
end with by saying keep it crispy it's
How We Do keep it crispy she's dead
[Music]